oh shalom whitney cummings here gonna do
a quick intro for this
guest i almost said panelist that was
weird jessica batten
is famous infamous notorious for kind of
being the villain on the most
famous reality show of all time love is
blind
hot take i
don't think she deserved to be dragged
publicly the way she was dragged
publicly
um we talked all about it i begged her
to do this i'm very excited for you guys
to
hear me uh passionately
tell her it's okay to get blackout drunk
on television and we've all been there
if you want to listen to me rationalize
my own behavior by defending her this is
the episode for you
real quick um the tour is in full swing
a lot of the shows are selling out and
then you guys get bummed and you get mad
at me so
uh denver colorado is this weekend
october 23rd that i'm in milwaukee
wisconsin atlanta georgia i'm at the
center stage theater we're doing two
shows the first one sold out
next one has some tickets left atlantic
city is sold out sorry we can't add a
show out of my control then i'm in coral
springs florida which is basically miami
so all you miami people that
text me at 4am on cocaine
whitneycummings.com then i'm in orlando
florida royal oak michigan we added a
show that's basically detroit green bay
wisconsin minneapolis i'm back in many
oh milwaukee is not the same long m
words i really conflate boise idaho
seattle washington columbus ohio
cleveland chicago chicagy we added a
show in chicago
there's many more
whitneycummings.com don't just google me
random porn will come up my last name is
a nightmare enjoy jessica
[Music]
are we rolling that do i look like an
insane person or like i mean for me
oh see you know what happens this is the
new hair color and i didn't want it to
wash out for you so i didn't oh fuck
okay i wanted to be bright and vibrant
for you so i didn't wash it but now it's
like greasy i love it that's not out
there sure not at all do i look like
chucky no no sexy chucky it looks
amazing with that shirt too thank you
wait
i have my new mug theranos early
investor i don't even know where i got
this but thank god for bad decisions uh
after a couple hits of weed because i
got this mug out of it
what um uh is your take on her do you
like do uh elizabeth holmes you follow
her i you're in the tech world okay so
um no
right um i think she she wamboozled
quite a few people though so i mean
she had everyone and their brother and
walgreens
you know thinking that she had this you
know
movement essentially going to change the
healthcare tech world um as we know it
and
lo and behold she was wamboozling
everyone yeah but i
okay can i play devil's advocate with
well we gotta talk about you we're gonna
talk about you so much but just because
you're in the tech world anyone that is
in the tech world that i can talk to
about this yeah do you feel like you
knew sooner than everyone else did
because it seems like people the techrow
were kind of like we sort of knew that
technology wasn't available but we all
just figured she knew some shit we
didn't i didn't i would say probably my
ceo and his peers a lot of them knew
yeah um
just because
there's so well you know i look at the
story and i go i'm in the sales aspect
of tech and i go
how was this not found out because i'm
trying to get a deal done and we have to
go through security reviews and they
have to see everything mocked up and
they have to take a trial run of it and
she kept saying you know it's almost
done it's almost done and they never saw
it really play out right they were just
they wanted to be
you know attaching themselves to this
thing that was going to change
healthcare
right and look it's it's fast there's a
co i have a couple of bad gamblers takes
on this because it's like on one hand i
want to go
everyone fakes it till they make sit
right not grammar but you know what i
mean everyone's gotta fake it till they
make it every guys have done that
they've been like yeah i got it we
better figure this out like or if i just
had more money i can figure this out if
if someone gave me two billion dollars i
could probably figure out or hire enough
smart people to figure out how to make a
prick of blood
get faxed to a like uh
the satellite or whatever her technology
was you know what i'm saying with that
much money you'd think you know in 10
years you're she's gonna figure it out
but
there's something fascinating to me
about it because i'm almost like if the
technology did exist i feel like a man
would have already invented it
i know that's a horrible thing to say
but like let's be honest if it was
possible it probably would have been
done already well i mean it would have
been badass to see a woman and i think
this is the worst part about the story
is how cool would it have been to see
her really thrive in that
and really you know
be an honest person
um but unfortunately for us yeah she was
a total fraud do you think she knew she
like because i think sometimes people
like that and not to diagnose whether
it's like malignant narcissism or
sociopathy or whatever do you think she
knew she was lying
yes the answer is yes wait i just
listened to a podcast called the dropout
it seems like she did know yeah i
listened to that it seems like from what
they're telling us but also i'm someone
who knows there are two sides to every
story and we've seen the entertainment
portion of this story right with the
documentary and with the podcast so we
can play devil's advocate too and now
the trial's going so we'll see kind of
how that plays out and what really
happened um
but yeah it seems like
you hope that she was well intentioned
that her heart was in the right place
she really wants to change
the world and healthcare it's that's
great um hopefully she wasn't just you
know trying to make a buck at some point
she would have had to get the product to
a point where it could be really used in
walgreens yeah throughout the world but
she had to have known that i think to me
like people like this come along and
they hold up a mirror to society and i
think that i guess for some weird reason
this is coming up on your interview
where is i think you were someone that
was um has been like chosen
by the universe by whatever you believe
in by god
to sort of be this
lightning rod
that
you know
uh
brings out the best and worst in
everybody based on the rorschach test
of you know the way that you were i
believe incredibly brutally and i'm
gonna say it unfairly cut
on love is blind for whatever reason
god the universe gave you this
responsibility to be the lightning rod
that gets everybody talking
and lets everyone's shadow um be seen
you know so to me
there's two kinds of people in the world
people that like licorice and people
that don't
and there's people who
understand what happened with you and
people that don't know
exactly what i mean exactly for the
people that
were to ever see you know love is blind
you've all seen it fascinating
experiment of a show
anyone in the right mind goes oh
you guys that was just a brutally
unnecessary brutal
cut
you know right and
um i have many thoughts about it i want
to talk about it but i'm a little bit
walking on eggshells because i do feel
like i'm talking to someone that's been
like traumatized
by reality television yeah
yeah i mean
the trauma is real um but i think you
know coming out on the other side of it
and now that the whole story well most
of the story has been told and i'm so
thankful that connecticut netflix let
that happen yeah and still to this day i
can't believe they did um because it
does kind of show that there was quite
an edit on the original um
which by the way is is you know look
like
you know in scripted television we use
special effects and we use green screen
and we you know put things in later in
post we take things out you can change
the color of someone's eyes you can you
know do put add music and and stuff but
in they do the same thing in reality
television you know it's like you get a
very tiny sliver of what actually
happened and you bump up the music and
then you steal a couple reactions that
don't go where they actually went in
real life and then i mean as someone
that's spent a lot of time in
post-production and editing it's like i
would see
like duplicate reactions and be like uh
you know yeah they're doing their job
and they're doing it well
it just
i think breaks my heart for the person
that
you know i believe goes in with these
like really sincere intentions
and as someone that you know you have a
golden retriever i believe you that is
your energy yeah you are you have golden
retriever energy to me kind
love to everyone and then for that you
know to be what's taken it's just it's
i i don't think i would have been able
to deal with the frustration of not
being able to go well okay let me
explain what really happened sure yeah
and and it was frustrating on on so many
levels and now that you know some of
that has come out i feel
um a bit more liberated
but
yeah i think
overall um
super frustrating but i'm glad it was me
to be honest with you
and even though there were so many other
stories you could sit here for days and
talk about all the other things that
were going on behind the scenes with the
show my dog almost died for everyone
that knows me my dog is my child yeah
and i was working and i was on the road
and i was you know working 50 hours and
i just taken this time off
um so there were a lot of other stories
that had happened but honestly
i think
for those of us that are critical
thinkers in the world and realists um
there were some themes that came out of
this show that are kind of life-changing
maybe change reality television a little
bit in the way that we perceive things
in the way that we watch it and the
grace that we give to people
because you saw really two totally
different stories
um
and i think if i know a lot of my my
cast members are very strong as well and
some of them got pretty bad edits too
but
i'm glad it was me because i have a
whole
different life i have another career i'm
able to put up boundaries and and go
there and kind of get through all of
that and then
be strong enough to
you know i still can't believe i walked
back into that room and did all of it
but go tell the story and all of the
things that came out which really
showed a lot of biases um
and just
towards you know the male ego yeah there
were a lot of things that that came out
with that um especially and for with the
for example
for example um mark's
you know
the the story with mia mark you know the
fact that
you know mark was the victim and
um
that was really the whole story there
was so much more going on he was dating
other women yeah so it was that was one
hard to watch and two you're thinking
they just want to tell a story here um
but also they skewed pretty much
everything towards
a good male edit
all the women are crazy women will do
anything for love women are you know
desperate women hate each other women
hate each other right there's no
forgiveness
um and it's also tricky because in
something that you mentioned i listen to
you on um
um
talking on something and you know
someone asked you and is my goal in this
podcast to never ask questions that
you've already been asked um you know
because i assume everyone's googling you
or just watch the show and they're you
know getting suggested videos and
they're watching all of them so i never
wanted to you know be be redundant but i
think it is important to note someone
asked you when did you know
that you were
kind of becoming the star of the show
and you know
that that some of your inebriated
behavior might be getting highlighted in
the show and you said
uh something the effect of i started
realizing because of the questions that
were being asked to me so
so not only is it about what's been
captured it's then the narrative that's
being written after that based on the
the questions that everybody's being
asked yes is being coached towards that
so it's almost like you're at the point
of no return once that happens because
then
it's ordained the whole rest of the show
exactly and i think you know as much as
i was being called ageist
right because i was 34 at the time
okay can we just i'm sorry can we just
say no woman is ageless get the fuck out
of it get out get away from me okay the
idea like what will we not call a woman
in her 30s like what a woman in her 30s
having any kind of opinion we went crazy
psycho bitch
uh cunt uh cougar now we're going aegis
okay so if you're if you're in your 30s
and you date a younger man you're a
cougar but if you don't want to you're
ageist like when is it not your fault
right
there's always a label is there anything
we can do right but it felt like even on
set when we got to mexico and i pretty
much knew immediately because the person
that i saw in the pods and the person
that played out in real life there was
just such a difference and i got in over
my head of course i was telling myself
this is such a once in a lifetime thing
you know um it was a little bit of fake
until you make it to be honest i'm going
why am i here yeah i must be here for a
reason this is all coming together he's
from chicago but like there's millions
of people from chicago yeah but also
it's i think it's so weird because i've
been thinking about i was very scared to
reach out to you because i was like it
seems like this person just needs to
forget about this entire experience yeah
like it must be traumatizing to have
people even reaching out to her like
does she even want to be known for this
you mentioned somewhere that gwyneth
paltrow said like who doesn't know
jessica batten like you've become like
famous overnight for the maybe some
moments in your life that you're the
least proud of right that's why you have
to hang out with comedians more because
it's what we do
we basically our most embarrassing
moments we put them on social media
right we advertise them so you should
hang with us you start monetizing your
mistakes i love it and so i was really
trepidatious because i was like i don't
want her to
have to think about this anymore talk
about it but um you know and it seemed
like you were sort of not doing press as
a choice right right do you have that
choice
i didn't really have
much opportunity to do press
um but also didn't really want to right
after that initial show came out right
which is so tricky because my instinct
was like i need to set the record
straight i like the fact that we're able
to go like i'm just gonna let this go
and people can have the feelings they
have and come up with their opinions
about me that they're gonna come up with
and i'm just gonna have to let that
happen yeah and the problem is uh
reality television makes sure that
you're under contract because otherwise
um you know they can't tell their story
so i had to keep that under lock and key
but i was pretty faithful
i was really faithful i'm christian and
um that was what got me through it i go
there's going to be an opportunity
there's somehow i meant to be in this
position and meant to do all of this
yeah and um you know lo and behold i was
able to kind of tell my story in the end
and i think help a lot of people
because during that time you know as
horrible as it was and i'm actually
super self-deprecating so i laughed at a
lot of it i didn't watch a lot of it um
but by the way i've heard you say that i
i
here's the thing i'm just going to say
my my take on on the cut the jessica
that we saw
i think the reason that it struck such a
chord with people is that we've all been
that person at the office party we've
all been that person at someone's
wedding we all forgot to have dinner and
had a tequila and then a little bit of
wine and then your favorite song came on
and you forgot to eat and you just drank
a little too much okay if i was on it
this is i mean we were shooting
something the other day and i was
thinking about it you because i was like
i've skipped lunch i'm scared i'm
stressed you know
i'm thinking about my appearance i'm
thinking you know i don't have my phone
like and now i have to find someone to
get married i would be numbing myself
within an inch of my life yeah you know
and
for me the fact that what came out in
you was just this amorous
snuggly sweetheart i mean
i think that the shout and freuda of us
all
cringing at it you don't cringe unless
you go i've done that i've been that
person right and then the harder you
criticize it the more you're trying to
distract from your own you know your ego
has to do that in order to strive from
your own um uh you know mistakes and
transgressions you made in the past or
your own embarrassment we're wired to do
that it's like the um
you know uh the roman coliseum it's like
we go watch other people get murdered
and killed and humiliated so that we
feel safe and relieved you know and you
sort of
you know have this incredible like when
i just look at like zoom out and go in
culture in the last couple years like
this could
like you might just be this
bizarre angel
uh in culture because you i've never
seen in reality television
someone do a harder more resilient 180
in terms of
um
getting the maximum amount of attention
and then handling it with the most
amount of grace and getting the most
brutal edit handling with grace and
bouncing back in a way that maybe your
life is actually better than it was
before
despite this
extreme obstacle yeah i appreciate that
and it's um it's interesting and one i
can't handle the cringe emoji that came
out right when the show came out i think
can't use it anymore i can't even see it
um because there were so many cringe
emojis coming at me and but cringes i've
done that oh god i've done that that's
what cringe is yeah we've all okay done
that what's interesting is it's funny
i've had
you know 12 year professional career and
i've you know i work in silicon valley
you know we're having parties every
night and i've never gotten out of
control too intoxicated nothing like
that we've taken crazy trips to napa and
i've never gotten out of control i've
watched other people do it but i've
always contained myself here's a
situation where life started playing out
in front of the cameras one we didn't
know this was going on netflix two
that's
you've got a 34 year old woman who has
her entire life been afraid of
commitment scared shit list of
commitments let's be more honest and
here i am by the way as you should be
i i don't think we should over
pathologize being scared of commitment
it's a huge deal it's the rest of your
life yes and here i am um and there's
all these like terrible airplane bottles
of you know barefoot wine
and
you know i'm on vacation to be honest
like i haven't had a three week vacation
in my entire career so i'm like hey i'm
not into this guy i'm gonna have fun
though not to mention the adrenaline the
anxiety like who knows with the neural
chemicals that are going on and i also
have a massive amount of social anxiety
and i've learned on the other side of
this it's like cup to face talking to
people you know having to be put in
situations with barnett and amber and
others um and just in you know in
general i've learned about myself if i
go to a party um i will be cup to face
or whatever is in my hand if it's edible
or
liquid or whatever um so i try to go to
my non-dominant hand protest
pro tip for all you uh social anxiety
folks that's fascinating
yeah it's a thing
if it's in your right hand you're just
going like
but if it's my left hand i'm just spill
it all over myself
if it's my right hand i'll be drunk if
it's my left hand i'll just look drunker
than i am
i'd rather take that frankly
that's genius well i um
i think that it's important to talk
about this because it's it's
uncomfortable and it's embarrassing i
don't when guys get you know have a
little bit too much to drink we're like
cool barstool sports like video goes
viral like
like they had a fun night but when when
a woman you know you know
sort of uh gets slightly inebriated it's
always like a mess you know
and i do want to show you something
really quick just so that you know i
have absolutely no judgment
i'm so glad that we had to reschedule
this because between the time that we
were last supposed to meet and now
i accidentally
uh got blackout drunk
during an interview
and acted like have no recollection of
my behavior when i say no recollection
of my behavior i watch the video and i
do not recognize the person speaking
i don't
you know when you like see yourself
drunk and you can be like i remember
doing that i don't this was like four
hours that i totally blacked out we're
working on this new um june shine
margarita flavor so i was testing all
these like canned margaritas and i guess
i
drank a margarita mix by accident it was
like supposed to be diluted among like
to like eight drinks and i drank half of
the bottle and it was 54 alcohol like i
just drank like oh my gosh like nine
tequilas or something in a row
and did not have dinner and
i mean this is when i say this is a
super cut of all some of the dumb shit i
did okay just so moving forward i want
you to know you are you have embarrassed
yourself the least of anyone in this
room
what makes me love you get out of your
emily she's a famous uh magician she has
a residency in vegas and i'm picking up
her cards being like are these marked
are these marked oh my gosh i mean i i
when i say
i was completely incoherent and
behaved in a way that i am just it makes
me
it eats me up thinking about it and i i
am we did air some of it just to go like
okay this happened i can't pull the
whole interview i don't want to you know
ruin it for her but
you know
just so you know there's no judgement
here well i appreciate it and this this
uh this is this chapter of your life's
over it's just starting for me so i need
some advice on how to manage being drunk
on television because oh man
it's your path it's my future that's a
tough one um well that makes me honestly
you know i don't look at that clip and
you know feel like shame for you or
anything like it makes me like honestly
love you more
but by the way that was the same with me
watching you
what you were doing it was like we've
all been that person i know what she's
doing i know what she's saying like
she's just trying to like figure out
this nightmare scenario so what drives
me insane is that people want to watch a
crazy reality show where you know
sensitive human beings that are looking
for
love that's already a predisposed set of
people that are going to be sensitive
they're going to be emotional the stakes
are high
you know um and put them in a very
intense situation
and then they don't want the situation
to be intense all of a sudden and then
when the people are all of a sudden
dealing with the intense situation
you're not allowed to act that way all
of a sudden like you're supposed to act
normally in a situation that's
completely abnormal yeah yeah no one
knows how to behave there's no set of
tools to apply here it's very true it's
very true it's a train wreck right and
that's why we sign up to watch it and
we're so enamored with you you want to
watch train wrecks when you see a train
wreck don't get mad at me i just added
fuel to the fire yeah there you go
but i actually have to be honest with
you you know i want to i want to talk
about a couple of the things because
there's so there's so much that happened
in your story line that is a part of um
just my that's my jam okay dating
younger guys let's talk about it i'm
like literally just here to come to your
defense on every single not that
anyone's attacking you anymore you're
like bitch where were you a year ago
when i needed you
right you're like i'm doing great no but
it um it drives me nuts because you know
look like
i a younger person it is different it's
not ageist it's ages to say okay grace
is 25 she uh we work together
i can't count on her for something
because she's 25. like that's not fair
there's certain things like
trustworthiness like reliability but
there's other things that just you can't
have in your 25 i would not date a guy
that's 25 or a girl that's 25 because
honestly like i want you to go
what is it fuck the wild oats whatever
it is go get it out of your system and
it's not like i don't want to be with
someone that doesn't have uh
all of that out of their system it'll
make me feel insecure
and it's just
that's just me i'm allowed to have that
preference right you know what i'm
saying yeah absolutely and it was like
little things like thinking about the
fact that he was still on his parents
insurance it's like what the hell
you know
you know what hard pass so if you this
might not even be an age thing i'm sure
there's a lot of guys that are 35 that
are still on their parents insurance but
if you have if you're on your parents
insurance if you still have roommates if
you still say crashing if you still have
a futon if you're still wearing jakar
noir or ck1 this is not a tenable
relationship like i why why
am i the asshole you know you know what
it is it's like this drives me nuts the
person that is
loved more is automatically the asshole
but also well
you love me for a reason because i'm rad
right
so why am i a jerk obviously being
worthy of love
and i think the thing too for me was
all i could base things off of is my own
experience right and i'm looking at this
24 year old going
dude i lived my life i lived such a
bachelor at
type of life for so long i worked on my
career and i changed and i evolved and i
grew and i didn't know looking back if i
were to marry the person i was with at
24 forget about it i would be in
alcatraz
had i married the person i was with when
i was 24.
i would be in thailand working for the q
anon blob in the wheelchair
i mean so the things he was signing up
for oh yeah
kids let's start now yeah let's do it
and he just wasn't giving it a second
thought it's like all right let's play
this out a bit here and you know
obviously that i went a little bit too
deep into that i think can i ask you a
question is there such a thing as going
too deep in talking about when you have
kids and a future with the person you're
about to sign a wild contract with is
there such a thing as being too
thorough 47 days
there's no such thing as constantly
asked questions 47 days it's wild to me
because because you because i think to
me you would have gotten shit either way
if you were like yeah let's do it they
would have been like oh
you know
women are so desperate to get married
they don't even ask questions or care
they're like let's just all that matters
is they're ringing the papers and then
when you do ask questions like why are
you being so neurotic why are you asking
so many questions like why do you care
why are you ages it's like
you can't win right but there were i
have to say
um i think these people are not very
rampant on social media but there is
this whole realist crowd out there that
we're getting through on social media
and being like of course you are asking
questions i don't care how you looked
but you're the only one asking any
questions like these people are signing
up these people are the crazy ones
they're signing up to marry someone in
you know a month you very much just came
off like the adult
well i appreciate that it's interesting
it's interesting now um
that i've been in a relationship for a
year and a half and we're engaged and
you know we're still we're taking these
exhaustive tests and we're meeting with
a therapist because i'm like i want to
make sure we're aligned on everything
you know i don't want to have anything
do that one you want to see what you're
signing up for ancestral wise oh yeah
let's make sure he's not 100 german like
grace
you want that nazi dna
okay
but yeah what like what there's no such
thing as being too prepared or you know
to research when it comes to the person
you're partnering with right and it
can't just be passion alone and i think
that that's the difference between you
and a lot of the other contestants is
knowing once you're in your 30s you have
this incredible um uh sort of empirical
wisdom that's like okay i've had lust
with people before that doesn't that is
like two percent
of the equation right you know that's
like two percent of what we need to make
this work you know lust is ephemeral
that has nothing to do with anything
don't let it trick me don't let it
blindside me and let's get down to like
the nitty-gritty is this actually going
to work as like a business deal because
that's really what a marriage is it's
kind of a business deal yeah and you're
a salesperson you're like how are we
going to make the how are we going to
make these numbers work because you're
on your parents insurance and these were
as soon as i started dating you we're
we're in the bread yes well meanwhile
i'm working 50 hours a week when we came
out of the pods back to atlanta i'm
working 50 hours a week and i'm on the
road and like i think he was working
five he's doing like two squats a day
ten hours so it was i mean
i'm going there's this isn't gonna work
you know there's so many things i'm like
i cannot reconcile this and you know i
in my heart of hearts i'm like i just
promised this guy the world and i felt
horrible about that but the thing that
you didn't get to see is how often
i was apologizing and just i'm so sorry
i am so embarrassed you know
my bad why should you have to apologize
this much because well you know i did
feel bad to me i feel like the
apologizing needs to
come to an end i feel like
i feel a couple things number one um
you know the amber thing and i like
amber like amber's i like that type of
bitch like the one the one at the bar
who's gonna like you know cause some
trouble be fun get in a couple like
i need to keep it in arm's length but i
appreciate that it's one of my favorite
type of like southern women you know
but
that
giving big compliments because a
critique is uh coming hard which is that
personality that is the like
accountability personality the i'm gonna
respect myself instead of boundary had
the roles been reversed which very
easily could have been
i believe that she would have been the
person that's like i'm not going to
apologize for my behavior when i was
drunk we're all adults here we know what
happens when we drink you weren't
married to him you were yeah exactly you
know it would have been like i'm not
gonna apologize for my behavior when i
was drunk everyone on the show is
drinking they just happened to give me
this particular cut it could have easily
been you guys so why am i the one that's
constantly apologizing we all we she
would say like we know what we signed up
for we all signed up for this crazy
experiment to go wildly wrong why are we
apologizing the fact that any of these
worked out is a weird miracle and no one
owes anybody an apology we all knew what
we were getting ourselves into so that's
what i don't like about this still later
going like you crossed a boundary you
overstepped it's like she'd be the first
person to go
i wouldn't have to apologize if you guys
were on solid ground like i you wouldn't
be giving me all this energy if i was
really a threat to you
i must i'd only be a threat to you if
there was something there
right so obviously you're threatened by
me for a reason and that's on youtube to
deal with yeah and it's crazy i couldn't
even conjure up emotion or like i was
i felt horrible i think to me
what happened at the party and then
seeing it play out um on television
several of the cast members just their
total lack of respect for me yeah was
mortifying
which is i think i think in a way
you know
it's it's really frustrating because it
really is a every man for himself
environment
probably because everybody on some level
knows they probably could have gotten
the villain cut you know just had to
cover their asses at all and let's just
jump on that wagon and stay in the good
light which is
a honorable thing to find out about
people on reality television you just
hope it's not true but i mean a lot of
these optics i think it's fight or
flight i think it's just a survival
thing i think you know
you know not to lower your the bar for
the people in your life and and sort of
their ability to step up but it's sort
of you know
to me the most badass thing the most i
think who amber thinks she is and what
amber thinks she's doing
uh
it would have been this
i think she thinks she's being the
badass i'm gonna respect everyone and
she could have gone you know what guys
it's clear that we all did dumb things
here some were caught on camera some
weren't jessica
drank too much we all drank too much
she's clearly getting this villain cut
she's already embarrassed it's already
gonna affect her life negatively it's
already way too much for one person to
be able to endure we all
are in this experiment together let's
stop piling on it's unnecessary right
it's not necessary anymore because if
the roles have been reversed she would
have been saying you're making
unnecessary drama you're trying to make
unnecessary drama exactly that's
probably what she would have said
exactly so just see yourself like just
the ability to have that i think that
the
i'm respecting myself in my relationship
and you know boundaries etc like don't
disrespect me don't be two-faced or
whatever it is like just go you know
what that was editing i know editing
works i know how this all works we're
all known now we all have instagram
followings let's now just be classy
about it like let's let's let's stop
trying to bring
morality into 10 days of us in boxes
drinking trying to find a husband
let's see you know i mean don't freeze
don't sign up for a show
where
you're gonna
basically have really intense probably
trauma bonds with a bunch of people over
10 days yeah a bunch of bonds with
people over 10 days and then when you do
find your guy
be blindsided and defended and upset
when he might have a bond with someone
else that was the point to have bonds
with many many people right and don't
let like
the producers play you on this do you
know what i'm saying exactly like be the
badasses that are like you know what
we're going to be above all this oh who
owned a role kind of and you've got the
guy and just go forward
but setting the record straight with the
amber thing
one that's not who she is to ever kind
of be that person um i have
i can't conjure up emotion towards it
yeah i don't dislike her yeah i don't
dislike him i actually wish them both
well and you say trauma bonds like i
feel bothered with them to be honest you
are i feel a bond with them i want
nothing more than their marriage to work
out i think they're adorable and i just
don't have any type of feeling towards
him in a romantic way i just don't you
know as much as everybody wants by the
way every conversation should still be
in in
reality it's not and look and i know and
i'm not always you know i'm me you guys
know i have hot takes whatever but like
i'm the person like two days before when
my guy friends are getting here i'm like
you're sure right this isn't just an
insurance like like
those conversations should always be had
i just and are always had i just think
it's one of the first time we saw one on
television and i think it was like
perfectly um
edited to look like you were kind of
trying to get him back like i didn't
feel that i didn't feel like you were
like trying to get him back yeah and i
think i was assuming that he was in the
same position i was yeah and i'm going i
just signed up for this hot dog are you
sure you must be in the same situation i
had no idea that his feelings had grown
this much towards amber and i do feel i
was unfair in watching that back to be
honest with you yeah um
but i was also i had this totally
different connection with him we were
talking tech
it was
uh we saw that kind of we saw it so yeah
so we saw that i was going they're like
licking tongues
together right and i'm going that's not
you you don't want that do you because i
only had my experience with them so i've
learned that right like let that be
that's what he wants that's what he's
doing and i guess that's what he you
know ultimately he chose but i was going
there's no way this is what he wants and
here i am in a situation that i don't
want i want him to have the strength to
not do this too i knew the optics
weren't going to be good sure but i
think i was trying to give him courage
in that moment like are you sure this is
what you want because we're we're really
you know
we're in this situation we know we're
going to get a good attitude if we say
yes yeah you know and i didn't want him
to be forced into that i didn't know how
much he loved and adored her and now i
see it yeah and i feel it wasn't fair to
me i will take that but
but
also how would you have known you had no
evidence you had no data you were just
going on the experience you had and were
behind
and i was i was working all day i had no
idea because barnett amber and mark were
hanging out at the apartment all day
talking about all these things so that
was also going on behind the scenes
and i think they were all getting each
other riled up about me yeah um
because he was saying oh she doesn't
want me and all these other things and
then he was like going on dates that
night but um yeah i think you know they
were all getting riled up about me and
here i am just trying you know i was in
this situation with mark and i'm going
this isn't what i want i wouldn't i was
kind of trying to make sure everybody
else was okay too yeah but now they see
it play out probably wasn't the right
strategy it's there's no right strategy
and it's like why what's the right
strategy there's no right to say the
right strategy is to have a strategy
but
i hadn't watched enough reality
television when i wanted to went on this
show but like mark had but that's what
interesting
there it is okay so here's the i saw
someone with a huge heart that was this
golden retriever that was like how are
you doing how are you doing i don't know
how i'm doing this is a little bit scary
i just saw someone that was very scared
and very overwhelmed
and trying to navigate it the best they
could and and
i relate a lot to you and i felt so
connected to you because i am one of
those
uh when i've had a couple drinks and
when i'm scared and uncomfortable i'm
gonna over share i'm gonna wear my heart
on my sleeve and i'm like are you okay
are you mad are we in a fight you seem
mad like i'm that per like i
am a dog with a bone
and
i can't let something go if i'm scared
like i need someone to
tell give me some kind of closure so i
can like move you're okay are you sure
you're okay and yeah and by the way
you've got 50 cameras around you got i
mean the level of just dissociation
but
i want to talk to you about mark because
i i believe that
i just it all felt a little
uh
i'm not gonna say rehearsed but it just
felt a little savvy to me and do you
ever get in there and as you're filming
does it ever feel
like it's tipping into a performance
sometimes this happens in real life
without cameras around you know
sometimes you're in a relationship and
you're like i just feel like i'm
performing or i feel like i'm saying
what i think i'm supposed to say or i
feel like i've just seen so many
romantic comedies that this is how it
should go or whatever we're all
conditioned in prime for that but are
you ever like
because these cameras are here i feel
like
we're performing and it's not as
authentic as i wish it could be
um
i think the only reason i felt a bit
performative was because i agreed to put
my heart into it and see it play out
even though i had already told mark i
didn't think we had a future
at some point i said look i'm here i
can't leave i have to do this experiment
so i have to try and make this work and
this could happen in real life right you
go look i'm gonna give this guy a chance
even though he's making my skin crawl
yeah because of whatever yes right and
so i'm putting myself out there
um
to actually engage in in those
conversations that's the only reason i
feel like it was a bit performative but
otherwise i think i was just really
honest i'm sorry and i mean i meant more
for him sorry oh for him
you i felt like we're so
[Applause]
like do you know what i'm saying uh yeah
well there's this um i'm not trying to
be shit interesting because there's this
psychologist
it's called psychology in seattle
when all this came out he did uh
he would feature each episode and talk
through what are all the psychological
issues for each of us yeah and
you know for me he's like she obviously
has a ton of unresolved trauma and a lot
of issues and stuff like that he's like
with mark i know everybody really likes
him i'm getting a really performative
feel out of him well lo and behold fast
forward to you know the story that was
just told for the world to see it's like
obviously you know the biggest thing for
me was on the wedding day we had decided
to say no
there was no saying yes and were you not
allowed to reveal that information until
recently
um yeah until recently i could say
interesting we had we had uh
how did you cope with no okay so on the
show he said i do and you said i don't
you had previously agreed off camera to
both say i don't right and then he said
i do
right in some way
kind of throwing you under the bus
ish 100 throwing me under the bus 100
throwing you under the bus and then for
a year you had to just let people think
that's what happened because you weren't
allowed to mm-hmm
what does that mean extreme example is
being on death row for something you did
not do yeah because
you know now that i'm able to tell the
story it's like he was dating other
people at the time this is a whole
different reality from what people saw
um
so it did drive me nuts to an extent at
some point i just i said there's a
reason i'm in this
you know and and it all unfolded in the
way that i'm glad it did people reached
out to me going i've been in this
situation i'm so glad that i'm able to
see someone else in this situation and i
see through it and
um for me the smart people do see
through it for me that helped because
for some reason it helped others
um but otherwise yeah i was pretty
pretty infuriating pretty frustrating
you are kind of this accidental healer
because you know the people that got
pissed off you're just showing them
their wounds you know or giving them
some kind of anesthesia to go like you
know pointing you know when we point at
other one finger at others we point
three at ourselves right or
the catharsis of going like i've been
through that you know and i think that
to me like during the time when the show
came out
in like text chains or talking to people
the most wounded people were the ones
that were the most mad at you the ones
that
you know
had the most unresolved trauma the ones
that had the most unresolved issues the
one that had rage stuff that had
addiction issues those were the ones
that you know i think need to
go criticize to make themselves feel
better yeah you know so it was like just
kind of and the people that were like oh
god she got a brutal edit or like oh god
like why would they film her if she'd
had that much to drink this is crazy
those are the people that i was like
okay you're good and i was able to kind
of really divide
like really very clearly and succinctly
be able to divide the people in my life
based on their reaction to you
yeah and it was brutal i mean imagine
having to go back to work you know and
i've built my career over you know 13
years and having to go back to work and
and face all those people and you know
they've seen it and thankfully i'm
surrounded by a lot of very professional
people that don't bring these things up
um silicon valley people what they do in
private not film is probably way weirder
than anything you did on camera in those
documentaries i like shoot goats with
lasers i feel like you're the least
insane person in silicon valley but i
would say
i would do it all again i would do it
the exact same way to be honest with you
like it's so
it's mortifying but um so many stories
so many um testimonies that have been
sent to me and
honestly just like looking at myself and
going how could you let this happen and
the work that i've done yeah on that um
let this happen as in doing it or just
having that extra glass i mean
all of it yes yeah because it's like i
am in settings like that all the time in
professional situations and this was
just way beyond me commitment is a lot
for me it's my number one thing like let
me sign up for the show
this is how like
in a horrible position that i was in i'm
going like all my friends are settling
down i'm supposed yeah i'm having this
like ridiculous pressure yeah and
you know i'm just pathetic enough to
sign up for this reality show to put
myself in the scenario and it's going
i'm going like this is your number one
issue is like commitment yeah you're
scared of it and let me highlight it and
be given all the alcohol in the entire
world and let's let this all play out
although at the time it was called the
atlanta singles project and it hadn't
been sold to netflix yet so i'm going
you know once it wrapped and like
hopefully this will all just
yeah you know
you're like i'm gonna go under the brave
thing i'm gonna just like jump off this
cliff because i'm actually after having
katie thurston on from the bachelorette
and and watching it i am so pro finding
love on reality shows now because
to me as i get older timing is
everything yeah i think and then being
in the same space at the same time and
wanting the same things and if you get a
bunch of people that all want the same
things and fight really hard to be on a
reality show those people are probably
all on the same page yeah you're already
with a group of people a sample that's
already on the same page so you're
already like your chances are going up
astronomically and you also have so much
in common already because you've made it
to this point you know and you're
probably both like you're throwing your
hands in the air you're comfortable on
camera like it yeah it dilutes a lot of
the people that maybe you just don't buy
with for whatever reason and then coming
out of it
you know
you're going to have some kind of trauma
bond going through it you're at least
going to trap a bond you know certain
chances of love i think are really high
so
um
you know i just think that it's it's
a little bit wild that
you didn't know it was going to be on
netflix you didn't know how big of a
show it was going to be like if they
came to you were like this is going to
be the biggest show on netflix and
there's going to be a pandemic so
everyone's going to be stuck in their
homes binging it and you're right that
was the uh yeah
carry on just like an hgtv lifetime i
was just thankful for the masks because
no one ever recognized me oh it was just
like mask masks sunglasses and hat like
here i come
now that we're out of the mask
see i planned this whole thing that you
know i would be able to go and tell my
story and then the masks come off and
now people are recognizing me
you're still dating in a pod basically
just with masks exactly
but um but so
coming back to work did you have to have
a big conversation you like with people
being like hey guys this happened
nope i did not have a conversation and
in fact do you wonder like has this
person seen it has this person seen it
like i would wonder that a little bit
but my colleagues actually uh reached
out to me first and said like we're so
proud of you and we're here for you and
my boss came to me and said you know i
get choked up about it because it's like
just the coolest culture that i work in
and i'm just so blessed for that um he
came to me and just said whatever you
need any time if you need time how do we
get you to be this fun at our work
parties
what were you drinking because we will
start providing it
the entertainment right
yeah that was i mean
that was the hardest that was the
hardest part but it was all also the
best part because it wasn't like i was
going on this show to make a living
right i knew i was going to stay in this
swim lane over here so i just kind of
tapped out had my friends take my
instagram like it's you this week you
know you're covering and i was just over
here in the swim lane and you know no
one would really talk about it and i
kind of just could go back to work so i
was blessed for that but is there
something like what why did this happen
to you like it's like you you everything
happens for a reason yes and i know you
um you have a strong christian faith
it's it is because when you and look as
someone i've had a lot of negative
attention
um and
in one fail swoop and at the time i was
not in a place where i understood what
it was to me it was all personal
criticism i thought everything was
personal towards me where it's like it
was someone else the day before it's
gonna be someone else the day after me
like
it's just pain it's people's pain right
so the people that appreciate you or the
people that saw themselves in you the
people that saw that it was a bad edit
the same people don't comment at all
really the ones that are like oh god
that's a bummer oh god she probably has
to go back to work and deal with this
freaking you know her most embarrassing
moment yeah those guys are not they're
not in there
it's not a thing it's just the people
that are like getting off on the
self-righteous indignation because
self-righteousnation it is a drug right
it gets it produces adrenaline and turns
into dopamine so you've been exposed you
are you
very few people understand how much pain
there is out there you understand this
because you've felt negativity come
towards you anger is just pain like what
do you do with that information now that
you know how much pain is out there or
are uniquely qualified to understand
that
yeah and it's um
it's a lot on your nervous system right
it's like thinking about and this is one
thing it's a very extreme example i was
a people pleaser
you know and this was an extreme way to
kind of heal that
um
but
just thinking about one person being mad
at you it can drive you nuts right so
think about the world being mad at you
and um
so it healed that for sure that's
fascinating yeah
people pleaser i mean i
you know i was always involved in
everything i've always been
kind everyone pretty popular all these
things but it's always been a problem
like if someone's mad at me i'll lose my
mind yeah because i'm like oh my gosh
what have i done unable to tolerate the
discomfort of others yeah and now it's
i'm in this situation well you have no
choice because if everyone's so mad
quote unquote me i'll put me in quotes
it's not really you yeah the idea of you
because uh you just actually go by jess
jess okay so
jessica
um from the show
and um it's called boundaries you know
it's like you've got to put up
boundaries immediately i was able to go
into my career thing and you know thank
god netflix provided a therapist for me
which now is just part of my weekly
the same one
i've changed and now i found like my
soulmate therapist okay great great
which is just how do you know when you
found your soulmate therapist like how
do you know
uh
i mean is it what they say or what is it
what they say or who you are when you're
with them it's who you are when you're
with them and how you feel about
yourself kind of like a relationship
right it's how you feel about yourself
when you're with them and you have to
trust them fully
um
and
yeah i mean i think
you know you know their vibe too my my
counselor is always like i don't have
anybody after you like her her alarm
will go off she's like i don't have
anybody after you and i'll stay another
hour and a half
and she'll she'll bring things out of me
i've never told anyone and once the
truth starts coming out of you it's
addicting
yeah it's things you don't ever want to
say once you say it you're just like
because it's so freeing it's so freeing
you're only as sick as the secrets you
keep and when we're carrying around the
secret if you can just
i mean that's why 12-step programs work
so well and people you know uh
there's
phil stutz um a famous psychiatrist
talks about it in the tools and on marc
maron's podcast that he did an episode
of about it i don't know the exact
science of why but the way that your
frontal lobe engages when you admit
something sort of despicable about
yourself shameful
embarrassing what traumatic when you say
it out loud and the other person just
goes uh-huh
that relief of grace that's like i'm
still loved this person isn't going to
go away because i've admitted that right
is produces dopamine in some way and it
uh stops your amygdala from being
activated which is the fear center of
the brain so it's like
saying
i shoplifted from
you know whatever bloomingdale's when i
was seven i took that and just like no
one cares that ship has sailed they saw
it on their surveillance camera you were
a kid but just saying it we don't
realize how much we carry around and how
much it eats at us on a daily basis it's
so true and they're so unbiased too and
they can't the information you give them
unless you're gonna hurt yourself or
others can i go out of the room right so
i'll even oh my god you must be so
traumatized messed up things in my mind
i will tell this woman i'm like this
came into my mind earlier and i know
this is f'd up and she goes oh
this is why you're feeling that and she
has this like really cool way of like
telling me it's like this is why you're
feeling that and just knowing that
there's a reason
just makes me feel less crazy yeah
totally and that signifies it and then
what was the yeah and you could have
grace exactly you know oh those are just
thoughts yeah you know where your
thoughts are flowing through you we're
not our thoughts like we can look at our
thoughts like um a science fiction movie
like the things that go through our head
we can just be witnesses like that was a
crazy thought that was a weird star wars
episode you know like why did i think
that i could magically change that
person's childhood by loving them like
what like it changes your life and your
experience in life when you can just
bear witness to your inner monologue
instead of subscribe to it as if it's
like the law right you know right and
i'm so grateful now having this is the
way i live my life now and therapy is so
normalized for me and i'll never go back
right and um obviously it was a crazy
way to get here yes but um like i
thought i'll be honest like i would not
change anything like even the crazy
drunk stuff like i wouldn't i would not
change it um
just so many people are you know reach
out to me and just are so thankful that
they saw me do all that stuff yeah and
it's cool you know and it yeah i think
it's like i don't know i i just thought
your grace
and resilience was so badass and you
were like i'm not gonna make excuses i'm
you apologized even though in my brain
i'm like you don't own apology you don't
own them that's what drives me nuts i'm
just like you don't need to apologize
for that you were inebriated everyone
was doing exactly what the everyone did
their job you knew the assignment you
knew the assignment and you showed up
and you faced the test and now you have
to apologize get out of here um so that
drove me uh that drove me a little bit
nuts so i think
i'm glad that you're out of the
apologetic stage
yeah you know yeah and there's also
something is there any relief in
you know
um
the couple weeks ago when i got blackout
like comatose drunk yet oddly weirdly
energetic uh in the gen kramer magician
interview
like after that happened there's a kind
of a relief when something embarrassing
airs or when people see it like i had my
nudes leaked a couple years ago
on the internet and there's it's there's
this weird like the shoe dropped
there's a weird um
piece
like a placid moment in knowing like
okay the worst thing
or the most uh stressful thing that i
can think of right now that could happen
just happened my news just leaked well
now i don't have to worry about my news
getting leaked no it's true maybe that's
like a crazy no stay nice it's a thing
because i go well i can't do anything
worse than that now yeah so i'm set for
life it's all downhill from here yeah
it's like i'm upset it's out there i
mean it is what it is and it's like
after you've faced that it's kind of
like what's the worst that could happen
and that's what i'm in that's my new
shit my new shit is like
uh
what are you gonna do hurt me
like like in terms of just bravery and
resilience in life like i feel like i've
gotten to the point i'm so grateful for
all my mistakes and all my heartbreaks
and all you know the the horrible things
that have happened to me i have such a
positive relationship with those now
because now i feel this weird
invincibility that's like you know in
relationships when someone's like i
don't know if this works me i'm like
what are you gonna do break my heart
bitch it's so numb at this point
yeah it's like there's i think you get
this like fearlessness um
that you didn't have before
exactly and you also
you categorize it too right so
trump being drunk on television
is you know
relative to a lot of things that people
are going through especially right now
so
you know i can kind of um
look at it at a different angle yeah and
just be grateful for other things yeah
and then when you you said that you went
back to chicago and like did some work
on yourself like to i mean
to get through all that can i just ask
you like what that looked like
yeah i was spending a lot of time with
my family
sorry one thing i will say is that as
unique as your situation there's also a
universal nature to it because
everyone's
you know done that thing at the party
they wish they hadn't done you know or
at the prom the night before taking that
photo like everyone has a version of
this yours just happened to be on sort
of a global scale but i think on
everybody's done it even if it's like i
should have said that thing at that
party last night and then they have to
go to school the next day and be like i
can't believe i have to face my
classmates after that i didn't
honestly
i didn't know the drunk thing was gonna
be a thing
well until i read a review two days
before that show came out
i didn't know the drunk thing was gonna
be a thing because
everybody was drinking everyone was
wasting it was so clear and i didn't
know it was gonna be
that dialed in on me yeah i knew what
the bachelorette
star was crazy
like look here
i mean look can you play you have a star
quality this is your fault i mean it
should have been so goddamn charismatic
engaging rights
oh my gosh i hate it when the camera's
on me i'm like can you teach me how to
get more cameramen to zoom in on my
stories all the airplane bottles
hello hello
lahayam
we now interrupt for just one second to
remind you that we have added 30 new
dates to the touch me tour they're on
sale right now if you felt left out this
fall because i wasn't coming to your
city because i'm a dumb whore now is
your chance to get tickets
uh to your city or a city that's closer
to you see my new power also make it a
night we haven't been out in two years
we haven't been able to go really do fun
things dress up look cute maybe throw on
your new fanny pack yeah okay put
cheerios in it don't wear shorts to the
show that's all i'm really asking i'm
seeing a lot of shorts in the front row
i'm seeing a lot of flip-flops with
funky crusty toes i'm seeing i'm seeing
a lot of pajamas let's pull it together
society's back okay now that stitch fix
exists y'all have no excuse
why am i on stage performing living my
dream wrangled all you guys to get here
somehow convinced you guys to spend
money
to spend a night with me
and then
i'm looking at you in a moo moo i'm
looking at jords i'm looking at skorts i
mean just nightmare after nightmare can
you please just get stitch fixed so i
don't have to look at you in a kilt or
else i'm gonna kill to myself
not all of you are dressing like orphans
though not all of you in sacramento
after the show we were doing selfies and
we were signing shirts this one fan came
up
and she looked very sleek and and chic
right and i could just like there was a
little shoulder peek she was wearing
this like tight black top and i realized
that i had the same one and it was sent
to me by stitch fix it looked so good on
her i lost my mind and started filming
her which might be illegal but i don't
really care i just had to show you guys
how incredible stitchers look in the
wild okay um uh she's obsessed with
stitch fix remember yeah and you took
the video let's roll the clip
where did you get this shirt i got mine
at the district where did you get yours
i got this from the lobby but i have the
same shirt and it's from stitch fix
we must have taken a quiz similarly
because i have the same shirt
it looks better on you
god damn
when you come see us on tour wear your
stitch fix i'll take a video of you i'll
put it in the ads
the point is we need you guys to do our
ads
please
if you're not signed up you have first
ditchfix get started today by filling
out your style quiz at stitchfix.com
whitney whether you're looking for a
brand you love or uh to try a new brand
at stitch fix freestyle you can shop a
range of over 1 000 brands personalized
to your size and fit and body that's
right 66 freestyle is your trusted style
destination where you can discover and
instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle at
stitchfix.comwhitney to try stitchfix
freestyle
stitchfix.com
whitney
okay so
look it was uncomfortable to talk about
y'all's
upsetting fashion choices but
buckle up because now we're going to
talk about lube
so
lube is a tricky subject i'm i i'm a
little bit
shy when it comes to talking about this
stuff um what
i'm very shy person
so
lube
lube is a tricky thing to talk about but
i feel very empowered after katie
thurston was on katie thurston
the bachelorette she talks so brazenly
and so shamelessly i don't even like
that word because it implies there
should be some shame in it
people are thirsting after her yes katie
thirsty cummings here's my joke what it
lubricates the topic oh oh katie lubrick
conversational lubricant
so
i'm going to work on being less like
uncomfortable and weird talking about
sex stuff because that's so 80s
okay so here's the deal lube is
essential it's not just if you're dry
down there it you get you got to get
ahead of it you know what i'm saying
because sometimes if you're if you're um
neurotic like me worrying that you're
not gonna be moist or as moist as the
guy expects you to be or girl whatever
because they saw in porn some cut where
a girl of a son just started squirting
out of nowhere within the first 10
seconds that's not realistic so you feel
like all this pressure to just like be
an octopus all the time you know
or maybe you're like me and you're just
very dehydrated and it takes you a
second to kind of get into it lube just
takes the stress out of every sexual
situation makes it less goofy and less
awkward i had never used lubes before
because
they didn't have good ones before like
in my day they were all chemically they
came in little bottles that looked like
they should be in a vending machine or
sold at a 7-eleven like hand sanitizer
but look at this
voila
just in time this is a
stunning glass
bottle look at this lube how gorgeous is
that it doesn't have like cartoon
strawberries on it i would keep that on
my bedside table and you wouldn't even
know it was lube right it's it's very
chic it's clean
the packaging isn't embarrassing do you
know what i'm saying this is like we're
going to have some classy sex not like
yeah we're going bang like we're going
to have some classy
sex everyone will be pleasured with this
lube okay fourier is offering a special
deal for our listeners get 20 off your
first order by visiting
www.fourierwellness.com
whitney or use code whitney at checkout
that's fourier wellness dot
com slash forward slash whitney for
twenty percent off your first order i
recommend trying their sex oil with cbd
you will thank me
later for bigger and better and a more
memorable orgasms enhanced arousal and
increased sexual
pleasure
going to chicago
one i didn't know it was going to be a
netflix show
we didn't know it was going to get sold
to netflix because the production
company that shot the show
they have a show called married at first
sight on lifetime right so they were
saying hey we're gonna try to get this
show on netflix and you know i wasn't
sure that was gonna be the case and they
were putting us up at hampton inn so i
didn't i don't know that i had a ton of
trust in that
um
right i couldn't even get through it i
started panicking it's stuttering i got
i got the had a fever dream i mean once
we got to the actual uh
production
facility we were like okay this is on
another level it's really like this is a
lot of came in yeah it was obviously
they had spent a lot of money on it when
did the when did um
yeah when did they come in they came in
the day
after so we showed up at hampton and
stayed over um the next morning they
showed up okay and you're like oh and
they were there when we were here like
this must be a thing
yeah i'm like this is a thing but i
didn't know because after we wrapped
there was a year and a half that we
waited so i was like oh this must not be
going through all right moving on with
my life but i'm still very traumatized
but like we need to we need a pandemic
to hit
we're just waiting
to come back on me
we're just waiting for a pandemic
we have a show that would work perfectly
independently right
oh that's probably how they pitched well
it really did because it was like so
people weren't touching they were
separated it was one of the only shows
that just sort of collided perfectly
because when the pandemic first hit and
you're
at the time where people were like
wiping down groceries and everyone was
like really paranoid and we thought we
were in like plastic contagion yeah and
when you'd watch a movie or something
and people would just you know
have a first date and kiss you like what
are you doing you're you know oh yeah we
were all so deeply
um
skittish that show was like they're in
pods they're not touching like it was
accidentally everyone was social
distancing
so it sort of was like the perfect
pandemic
show there's a new conspiracy i know
you've heard it here first wait a second
i'm just saying get me my tinfoil hat
um i will probably circle back to
the show a little bit if it comes out
but there's so much more to you than
this show and i think that someone that
comes through this kind of trauma is so
uniquely qualified to talk about things
like this i think that it it really does
just when you've and it seems like
you've just had a really hardcore
sort of year and a half to like get real
wise real fast so as someone that has
been on a reality show about finding
love i asked this on the show a lot
how do you know you're in love
how do you know
what is what is your definition of it
i think the definition of love for me is
the way you feel about yourself through
someone else's eyes
because
you know for me i need to remain an
individual i'm very independent um this
is someone that loves me for me who's
going to let me live my life the way i
want to live it and i love myself more
because i'm with them and it's kind of
the cherry on top of my life rather than
depending on them to make my life better
um
that is love and i've just recently
learned that
that's fascinating so it's the is is it
it's kind of like i'm not looking to be
completed i think we've been so
brainwashed to believe you need to find
your missing puzzle piece you need to
find the thing that's going to make you
whole it's like no bitch i'm whole
you're just
you get to be whole with me we get to be
two whole things together yeah exactly
instead of we need to like complete each
other yeah absolutely so i definitely
don't want to live like a codependent
type of relationship it's just not who i
am and after being single for so long
um i think like a five-year stint i've
just realized that independence is going
to be a part of my life and so the
relationship that i have um i need to be
able to have my independence through it
um but also after the experience that i
went through and candidly losing some
friends and having people kind of judge
me
it's been more important than ever to
have a partner who sees me in in such a
positive light yeah and um yeah that's
everything so you're cr your current guy
who i
sorry i do kind of have a crush on he is
such a stud
he reached out to you because he saw you
on the or saw you on a bike ride or
something but it's seen you on the show
so is this do you feel like he saw i'm
obsessed with this because my
dream
uh scenario uh
is to just be as much of a nightmare as
po to be like the worst version of
myself the first time someone meets me
it's like takes all the pressure off yes
so it's like you've seen it you've seen
what i'm capable of you've seen me sort
of like fall down it's all downhill from
here yep no and if you see through this
and see my heart and see who i am
because i don't want to be like
pretending to be this perfect person all
the time because that jig's going to be
up at some point it's the truth though
it's the best thing because i could just
be who i who i was it's so hot to me
that your guy who's a foot surgeon which
is the hardest thing to do by the way i
do know this all those little tiny bones
feet are a nightmare yeah and the
bunions i have an extra bone in my stick
you tell him that oh
i didn't know everyone has foot problems
until i started dating him everyone i
mean everyone i introduced to him oh god
talk to you it's my achilles heel is my
foot
is he like a celebrity like when you go
out with like a specialized surgeon and
you move everyone's like i gotta talk
about my ankle i gotta i gotta show you
this toe oh they're just taking their
shoes off oh yes
my friends are like sticking their feet
in his face like three minutes after
they meet him it's like saving the world
one bunion at a time
um that you have to look at a lot of
feet yeah he says he likes me for my
feet so that's that's it actually that's
that's how we got over the uh the edit
of love is blind we did
you probably you must have amazing feet
they're not bad really
what what okay this is a big i am gonna
get granular here because you happen to
be engaged to a foot surgeon and i do
have a perfect score on wiki feet don't
worry perfect i have a perfect sport
okay yeah i'm not quite i'm not quite
perfect that was a bad angle but we
where were you
when did we see your feet
plenty of times i think there's like a
hundred photos on wikifeet oh wow okay
there's a lot um i don't wanna ben loves
going on there though maybe he does have
foot fetish he's just coming to the
surface
oh great okay does he have you guys
talked about that at all like does he
know the uh biological basis for fetish
we've been talking about this on the
show before oh and we haven't yeah yeah
i'm not sure because i think freud said
it was uh because
toes look like little dicks
there's another theory
that is that when babies are crawling
around
they could if their mom was barefoot
like they're associating pleasure with
like seeing their mom's feet because
that's all they could see you know
before you could stand up
oh my gosh i'm really freaked out right
now
i'm not going back home i'm staying also
this is the other thing do you know
about this hold on i'm sorry i have to
do this don't watch this ben
this part of your foot when you do that
is a vagina
why
that's what happens when guys fuck feet
they fucking through there
i know i just learned this crazy
but it's a very big thing i think
there's so many correlations there's
something in with the like being
degraded also like i'm such a piece of
shit i'm gonna yeah
like i i'm just gonna get your feet on
me or something like leave
yeah like my feet aren't that bad it's
not that much of a punishment is it is
it that big of a punishment dream or
whatever no i'm good um
okay i love that and you mentioned
earlier your love language do you know
your love language
ah love language is affirmations yours
is affirmations yes so what are the four
physical touch
acts of service gifts and affirmations
yes and did you guys take the test
together
no
i think we just knew our love languages
okay um so he's touch okay physical
touch
yeah shocker a man is touched right
twist yeah it was tough like we got
engaged and then i came down with
breakthrough kovid unfortunately and i
knew his love language was touch but
then i really knew his love language was
touch and he had he would have like a
mask and come in and give me my soup and
just like take off he's great at acts of
service actually he makes me a smoothie
every morning
took great care of me during covid
so he's just he's a service guy i love
this guy i'm a touch guy i'm
affirmations i like it's crazy what does
that look like what is that how does
that manifest it's so wrong so it's like
like i love you so much i miss you just
thinking about you period yes that's it
like every day every day that's not
asking a lot because i think to me
i've said before like if i don't hear
from you
like it's just whatever my abandonment
whatever it is
i would love to just hear from you every
day well i'm thinking about you
i don't i just don't know that i just
need all right we'll need to know again
just a little proof in a couple hours
yes it's come back up yes but being
still there specific about it because i
think that
that i mean if it's the right person
they're going to be okay with hey
when you're at lunch could you just send
me a check-in you just like check it out
well i was at lunch i was talking about
you the whole time
i didn't know that
it's like what i say and how
people talk um nice behind
your back but shit to your face
i was just talking about how amazing you
are can you let me know exactly just let
me know next time yeah instead of every
but every stranger you meet i tell
everyone i mean about you tell me how
much you like me yes because you can go
on and on if people don't if other
people don't need that if your partner
doesn't need that yeah you can go days
and days without saying those things
especially you know ben is so busy he
has kids there are other things that are
coming up yeah so kb let's check in here
and we do this thing on wednesday where
we have to check in because we've gotten
you know some of these weeks where we
just haven't communicated enough so
we've learned if we have a check-in
every week at a certain time then you
know we can give each other those
affirmations which is nice i love that
and it's almost like is it like a like a
set time that you protect yes checking
in hi this is what's uh bugging me this
is what i meant to ask you this is what
i meant when i said that it's like yes
like
um you know when you clint the uh a
clint clean the lint off of the dryer
thing you know what i'm talking about
make sure it doesn't start on fire you
know what there's like a like a what is
that called like the filter when you
clean the dryer filter dryer filter
that's what that feels like yeah just
like scooping out all the lint on the
dryer filter that's exactly it
just like any unresolved presentation
you're like i'm so glad i just did that
because this place would have caught on
fire yeah
it's a great parallel it's just like
getting ahead of it the little because i
i'm finding that in relationships it's
death by a thousand cuts like i think
most relationships people he cheated or
she cheated or she lied about money or
she
most of it is just a slow death by a
thousand cuts of like resentments and
unresolved tiny little things that we
don't have right time to repair every
time it happens right so then over time
it just turns into you don't understand
me and all these little tiny things have
turned into one big tumor of resistance
yes
i've experienced that too and i think
one of the things i did take from love
is blind um
that was a good thing is
i tend to be very even keel i just want
to be chill let's go have fun even
though there's something bothering me
back here like a little something um
rather than ruin that perfect zen moment
of you know bringing that up i would
rather be even keel the thing that love
is wine taught me is just get it out rip
the band-aid yeah you've got to talk
about this now because you're going to
marry this person in 30 days you don't
have a lot of time to resolve this later
yeah there's no putting up you're going
to put it out there now yes if
something's bothering me yeah still do
you just like to have fun i think you
should and and i think you should
because it's unfair
to the other person like
i wouldn't want someone not telling me
it's my whole thing with codependence
when someone's you know
uh is like um
you know do i have to go to this party
and like i have to go to this
bachelorette party tomorrow i have to go
to this baby shower tomorrow i'm like if
i was the person hosting that baby
shower it's my nightmare that someone
would show up so because they had to
it's my nightmare that they were going i
do have this freaking baby shower
tomorrow oh like don't come right please
don't come if that gives me so much
anxiety to think people don't want to
come to mind if this is out of
obligation you're not helping me by
showing up at something you don't want
to come to
and because you think i need it i'm fine
right what i what i need is for everyone
that's here to want to be here
and to not be going oh i can't believe i
had to go to that thing uh like just
don't come absolutely anything is out of
obligation and the and the to me my
biggest
i'm learning
fear is embarrassment you know they say
stand-up comedians we become stand-ups
to control how we're embarrassed
you know interesting because it's
imminent yeah and now we're just going
to control it because i was embarrassed
a lot as a kid i was like the bills
weren't paid at school so i'd have like
a like um a safety pin with a
like a bill on it and i'd have to wear
it around it's like unpaid so that my
parents would see you know that there
was like outstanding
bills or whatever you know they'd send
you home with like permission slips that
weren't signed stuff like that
i was just embarrassed a lot and uh and
if someone thinks something about me in
the moment tell plea i'm begging you to
tell me like i'm a big girl same please
tell me same i would rather you
over share
and then we can
reign it in later exactly than me not
know because i'd be thinking about it
and does this just literally just
happened to me in a thing where
someone's like yeah i've been thinking
about this i'm like how long
when i you're going i can't believe six
months ago you had this issue why didn't
you tell me so i just feel like it makes
me feel stupid oh yeah it's the worst it
makes me feel conned and it's like i do
on some level believe omissions are lies
because this is my life
is this my reality i don't understand
how people feel about me so now i can't
trust anyone so people are just walking
around with thoughts about me that i
don't know
and i'm just
like of course i'm crazy i don't know
anything tell me it's the worst feeling
yeah the worst feeling it makes me
paranoid yep
can i tell you
that we are the same roseanne uh uh when
i worked on roseanne
um she said something to me that was
really fascinating and for everybody has
you know
notes on her tweets i'm don't i don't
defend them um but she did say something
you know as someone that she's been very
traumatized in many many ways but she
very clearly said to me one day
like the thing that upsets me is when
everybody knows something except me
like when everybody
knows something and i don't and people
are too afraid to confront me about or
too afraid to tell me you know
or no one's being honest with me because
it starts to make you question literally
everything yeah and it makes you go
inward and be super isolated yeah
absolutely you know
absolutely that's i was just thinking
back i watched britney versus spears i
haven't seen it just thinking that was
one of the recurring themes
it's just like she never knew what was
happening um it was all happening to her
but she didn't have she wasn't privy to
any of it so she kind of isolated and a
nightmare
what what was the over under on that
documentary um well it was great timing
because afterwards you know now the
conservatorship has been released
um
but yeah they basically say jamie spears
was abusing his power as conservator and
you know poor britney the things that
she went through there were some people
that are now coming to the surface and
talking about you know some of the
nightmare experiences that she had and
you know they were working her to death
and they were making all this money off
of her jesus so it's pretty brutal that
is so so terrible that happened under
all of our watch i know it's so weird to
think yeah high profile people in the
world it's so embarrassing to think that
something like that was happening no
one's doing anything but it's like if
you don't know you don't know we didn't
know we didn't know um okay so you are
now engaged i am i want to talk some
wedding stuff okay i have some thoughts
okay
do you have to do a singles table
why does there have to be a singles
table why can't the single people
i think the single people should be
dispersed with the married people
because the married people know
other married people that are maybe
going through a divorce that are going
to be single soon it's a good idea don't
put the
all the pigs together
to just stew in their shit right put
them with the adults sprinkle them out
so that they could either figure out why
they're single or talk to people that
have
newly single friends the single table
always seems like such a um
so embarrassing insulting i'm one time i
was at the single table that was outside
of the venue there was the venue no
where to go it was downtown there was
like a big um uh tent and everyone's
inside and then the singles table is
like literally right outside the desk oh
my gosh
yeah we're just like the rats this is a
little insulting they made a movie about
it yeah which all the singles were crazy
and they were all all had their own
story lines but the common denominator
was they were nuts yes yeah but we don't
get come less nuts when you put us
outside by the gutter
right of course i'm screaming and drunk
i'm in the back no one can hear me
exactly you know and then no one's gonna
date me if i'm in the singles table
screaming
trying to get attention from the married
people that i just want them to set me
up with their brother great point
i agree
i think the table is out for this it's
got to be it's got to be out like if you
if that's where it gravitates if all the
single people gravitate together that's
great but the pressure of a singles
table we're all single should we date is
so awkward it is a bit insulting it's
like last night i went to this uh event
it was a doctor's event a doctor's event
yes sounds like a real razor
these guys are fun though you know
what's so fun
is they get out their phones and start
telling you about all these crazy cases
and all these people that have stuck
things up certain areas and it's well
the stories they tell are actually
incredible but there's a lot of fun
there's a lot of wine our
bananas
oh yeah they're a lot of fun too yeah
you get the right one yes well they have
access to painkillers they see them just
saying how their day went
is more shocking than anything any
comedian could ever come up with it's
crazy like there's there's some days
that i get done you know selling a bunch
of software and you know i tried i come
up with a way that you know i've saved
the world by doing that
and ben comes home and he's cut off like
two people's feet that had diabetes and
saved their lives and i'm going oh my
gosh you are like a hero and you've
dealt with all these things
emotional and
he's just the sweetest heart is he the
one that uses the saw oh absolutely yes
and he has i've seen photos i'm so proud
of him there's all these people around
him and he's in there you know doing his
work and
it doesn't gross you out at all
um some of the photos that he shows me
will gross me out
um
but i'm kind of used to it at this point
yeah and it's hot yeah it's hot and it's
like he's like saving people's lives
every day it's it's really cool i have a
question for him someone that i worked
with
got a foot transplant he has someone
else's foot oh dying so where to go i
don't think he's done that one yet it's
nuts that's what it's a little gray
oh it's not it doesn't look cool it's
spray tan yeah
we didn't get him some sally hammer
spray tanner it looked it looked like a
cadaver's foot it did not look
like it was in fantasy i don't feel like
this took this isn't really good is this
your halloween foot
um but uh i was going to tell you my
insulting table last night tell me oh so
this guy
he goes let me take you so all the
doctors were canoodling and he's like
well let me take you over to the wives
table
was the handmaid's tale right
martha's we were watching we're watching
football which i'm a huge football guy
and um he's like let me take you to the
wives table and they weren't watching
the game and stuff i was like alright
guys we'll see you later um but it's
kind of like the singles table it's like
yeah with the wife's table see yeah
exactly but i let me ask you something
as you're saying that my brain is going
do you go over to the wives table and
they're like yo jessica
no
or do they already know it's interesting
i never really get that
until after
they put it together i had yeah i go on
uh solo dates a lot because i miss
traveling and being incognito and all
those things
went on a solo date the other night and
i was embarrassed because i ended up
getting like a five course meal at this
place i got like two things of sushi did
you say solo date just you yeah yeah i
love that i got out of spin and i went
and um i have to i have to get out i
don't travel now and i'm used to it so
i had a solo date i had way too much
food it was embarrassing well it was
just me and then there was this lovely
woman sitting next to me and i said i'm
really embarrassed that i just ordered
like a five course meal and you guys
just got the ramen like i got a little
bit of everything over here um and she
was so lovely and we had this full
conversation and then the next day i got
a message in my instagram said hey i'm
so glad you know we shared our first
bowl of ramen together last night and
you know it was so lovely to meet you
and you're going holy shit she knew who
i was this whole entire time and that
still shocks me
and i have that happen all the time a
lot of people don't say are you jessica
i get that
what would you rather
uh i like it all because it's it's like
the coolest thing i love talking to
people and they know who you are because
i have like a stranger complex but now
it's like no one's a stranger there's no
way it is yeah there's no um
social awkwardness anymore you don't
even have to introduce yourself right
it's like you're but you're also already
really close to people
i'm saying it's like you're it's like
there's this intimate connection with it
yeah
oh yeah right
yeah it's true and it's it is actually
really cool like we've already partied
together like we also
saw you during this pandemic time when
we were all like at home and traumatized
like it was yeah i think that the shows
that came out and love is blind i think
being the reality show that came out
during the panama were extra bonded to
like the other one for me was netflix's
cheer
and all right i love cheerleading it's
i mean it i shouldn't have bonded to it
this hard i mean it was like you got
like the pom-poms i owned and we like
went to navero in texas
monica is like one of my best friends
now they're at the house all the time
like okay this is i do love cheerleading
but this is a little ridiculous you know
i think because of what was going on
there was this extra level interesting
investment but yeah we were like trauma
bonding for sure you know with you you
were sort of
getting us through it in a way one drink
at a time you were but you were this
like mass anesthetic you know you guys
you took us
off you took us away from
we're gonna die soon like you did that
in the way you're this like angel oh
well it's my numbing right and it's
watching this it's watching this train
wreck yeah and you're just going like
what's gonna happen yeah right
um
so yeah i feel that i feel that when i
meet people it is and i go all over the
place and i meet people from everywhere
and i'm going there's people in jackson
holding know who i am like what is this
life
and um it's not this like fame thing
because i don't feel like famous i just
feel like an everyday person and i go to
work every day
and it like shocks me every single time
i go babe she slipped in my instagram
she knows who i am what
i get still to like every time it
happens i'm going like this cannot be
real so it's wild and it's the crazy
thing is this netflix show is all over
the world yeah it's just people in
brazil
and you know all over the place and
apparently they're coming out with the
love is brian brazil
i don't even know about it comes out
tomorrow
with a different cast or different cast
comes out tomorrow
i wish you'd got some back end on the
show
how are you feeling about new year's
weddings labor day weddings destination
weddings
uh
i like all of it really if people have
an extra vacation day look a new year's
eve wedding is a little aggressive that
steals the new year there's two things
yeah on one hand just give me something
to do because new year's it's so
stressful anyway and we're always
looking for ways to make it fancier than
it is like i'm gonna wear a sparkly like
handkerchief top that's gonna chafe my
nipples
right anyway so it might as well go to a
wedding and make it like super fun and
not like just like
three of us sadly dancing in our
apartment on new year's so i i'm so for
new year's weddings but at the same time
i'm like
you maybe not new years labor day i
think is great yeah
and then but
okay but destination absolutely how far
is too far depends on is it a good
destination good point um
i've not done i've done a mexico wedding
i haven't done anything like in europe i
think if you have a destination wedding
you have to be comfortable with only the
weirders showing up
really don't you think
like you might only get the rich weirdos
oh you might not get if it's on a
weekend yeah you a friend of mine got
married in italy the most beautiful
thing i've ever seen she gave us a
two-year notice like plan a trip around
this and everybody came yeah but
i think that if you don't give enough
notice it might just turn into all the
like weirdos come
oh i hadn't thought about it wouldn't
you be scared i'd be scared to do a
destination wedding yeah like what if
everyone can't make it oh i am
reconfiguring like none of my friends
have passports like i don't trust any of
my friends to get their shit together
enough to have a passport ready like i
don't know any like half my friends
can't figure out an
american charger much less a european
charging port like i can't converter
like i just can't
i can't let anyone that i know loose
in croatia it won't go well
like i just know it's going to be bad
well my thing is too i don't want anyone
to go out of their way so i haven't
solved for that part of the people
pleasing interesting
interesting
now i really people that sat through my
love is blind wedding the worst
you know i still owe them um which by
the way i think it's important to just
mention for the people that haven't um
heard jessica talk about this because
you haven't really talked about it very
much you know in terms of setting the
story straight of that when you showed
up at the wedding which you both had
agreed to say no all of a sudden there
were like 20 family members there of
marx like it was a circus so you must
have known on some level okay there was
something going on that i didn't know
about right why are all these family
members flown in for us to both say no
yeah and and even worse than that
i had two bridesmaids so we were
obviously gonna have two and two he had
like six groomsmen
so he had planned this whole thing
behind the scenes um and then even
afterwards when
you know i said no and then i had to
come out and face him
and it was this whole performance of i
can't believe you said no and i'm going
like
i just want to go dude and just shake it
i'm allowed to say that on camera like
around and i'm going dude what are you
doing yeah like you can't be this
evil you know like
what is going on here i've got punked so
hard
and so now you're in this situation
where you have to set the record
straight and you are such a kind person
it's so clear it must feel gross to even
have to do this terrible but you haven't
done anything wrong right and you know
i think that's what's that's what's so
hard because yes i do have to set the
record straight and some people are like
oh she's coming out and you know he's
trying to throw him under the bus now
well he didn't show up
right yeah and also he screwed over lc
and that whole story played out and it
was like the same exact story so it's
not like my word against his it's like
our words
against his and he didn't show up to you
verify or
you know yeah
so it just drives me nuts when when
somebody does something sketchy and then
you have to be the bitch yeah so now so
so you did something to make me look
like a bitch and now i have to defend
myself and now i look like a bully
because i'm standing up for myself like
i cannot stand that that drives me nuts
yep it's it was so easy for me to stand
up for myself though good because
you know i reached out to him to do it i
reached out to the girl to do it which
is embarrassing on some level on my part
but at some point
you know as um
graceful as i looked when i had to go on
the reunion and on this follow-up show
it's not always like that there's very
very tough times in
this story yeah and on those hard days
you know one of them i i wrote her and i
said
please like you've got to do something
he's not gonna come out and say what
happened yeah like
and i couldn't say anything yeah yeah
you know so i did ask her to and she
never responded yeah this is a girl that
he was basically dating simultaneously
with you and being shady about just
being like hey can i get some help here
you know yeah yeah and i mean they dated
for a year and a half
and the week before the show went live
all the photos came off i mean they were
living together they had a dog all the
photos came down and it's like yeah
ghost never existed right right so which
is by the way bless her heart godspeed
whatever it um
you know we forgive others not because
they deserve forgiveness but because we
deserve peace but to me it just was it
was just kind of this really unfortunate
confluence of like dude if all the
if y'all just like all aligned
such amazing things would happen you
know it didn't turn on each other like
in terms of like the women turning on
you i just like that just really
nettled me my nirvana would have been
for mark to show up and us to both say
our piece on camera yeah and he didn't
have to look bad right no tell your side
of the story dude what are the chances
that two people that met for five days
through a wall and they got married in a
box this should never have worked out
like this of course it wouldn't have
both human beings we're adults we took a
big swing we did an experiment
like it's fine let's be cool right it
would have been a partnership let's get
a dayquil partnership let's turn this
into a business we don't have to make
this nasty and sloppy yeah and i wish i
wish we could have gone out on that note
yeah i really do um we could be the face
of legalzoom
there's so many cool ways to spin this
and not make it have to be tough exactly
it would have been it would have been
such a great ending to the story but
because that to me is what drives me
nuts so i think that would i think this
is why comedians become comedians as we
have as neil brennan says in obsession
with justice like when when um there's a
dissonance happening that drives us
crazy so the idea that there was any uh
implication that that somehow you were
driving anything that's toxic to me you
were the least toxic
part of this it's toxic to pretend all
this other stuff didn't happen like
you're the one that's like i'm just
trying to be an adult and like move
through this and tell the truth and be
honest like why is that crazy you know
what it is it's like when you're around
craziness same people seem crazy yeah
when you're just trying to get to the
heart of the matter yeah that's a good
point i just see i just i relate really
hard to you it's entertainment you know
it's
are we doing a veil do we still need to
do veils i feel like a fail what's that
i'm a big veil guy big veil guy big veil
guy in the front that's going to be
pulled over i'm not one of those i'm
about to look i'm a big failed threat
guy
um
i prefer veiled threat to you so you
want to come down with a veil
i think so
and
you know are you worried it's going to
get in your lip gloss oh it's a good
point i know i don't know that's all i
think about i mean maybe i'll just go
with a mat but also can you not do you
ha this is the shit i'm obsessed with
can you wear lip gloss on your wedding
day because then you have to kiss him
and it's getting on his face oh oh you
do like a stain
maybe you have to go stain yeah
i mean
yeah now you're okay i'm making multiple
notes i haven't thought about any of
this shit okay
see i figured you had to like jam in all
of this
you know i just got this like wedding
planner it's this it's this thick do you
know where you're going to need a
wedding
we
i mean we're in love with santa barbara
yes so and we're we really like the idea
of eloping yes um so we're thinking
about that but also
i'm like
i'm not gonna miss the opportunity to
have a party and i want everybody that i
love to be there yeah um so we're still
trying to figure it out right we're so
once we got engaged we're supposed to be
going to cabo right afterwards but i got
sick right so now we're going to cabo
next week which we kind of said we'd
celebrate and so instead of getting
planning there
uh coveted in cabo you're going to have
montezuma's revenge in kabul
right
and then have you thought anything about
um honeymoon i love talking about this
kind of stuff italy i've never been to
italy i've always been saving it for my
husband so that's where we will go what
is your ancestry
you guys knew what was coming you knew i
was gonna ask this you knew it was
coming
german swedish irish fascinating
have you been there
no and that's something that i've
thought about well i've done a germany
okay but we thought about ireland as
well when did you go to germany 2015.
went to munich for what zoomed over to
vienna for what just there on a it was
like a christmas trip with an
ex-boyfriend was it fun
it was fun i love germany yeah um
[Applause]
my german fans are going to be pissed
i love germany it's just
it was bad weather when i went it's
always bad weather it was like it's like
um germany is crazy
it's it's crazy we had a lot of fun
there it's a very very gothic it's very
gothic it's very dark there's a coldness
uh there's an emotional coldness
i felt that i found that for sure it's a
very intense
place yeah there's lots of ghosts let's
just put it that way
children's ghosts
and sex parties
wait what they're sex duty is a wild
place okay yeah
totally agree benton was on a plane i'll
let him tell the story but benton was on
a plane recently with this german woman
who was in front of him who was in a dom
sub relationship i'm just saying that as
if i know what that means
and the
man it was all in german
and then she had to ask him
to eat she's like master may i plea he
was translating it
from german to english on his google
translate while he was reading her text
over her shoulder no
and she was asking if she was able to
eat and then he was sending her back
these crazy videos where he was having
sex with a woman with barbecue sauce it
was
wild um but germans go hard
i don't know if i'm ever gonna have
barbecue sauce again we just yeah we
just like watch porn in the shadows and
delete our cookies like adults
we don't have like wild sex parties
there was some photo of a
um there's some instagram feed of just
german men walking other german men like
dogs in grocery stores
there's a lot of like repressed emotion
and sexual energy
and ghosts in germany yeah dang i didn't
experience any of that
um
vibe wise it's just an intense place
yeah it's it's a it's a vibe yeah it's a
vibe for sure we haven't been ireland i
haven't been iron supposed to be
beautiful there are no snakes and
there's what no snakes in ireland
there's no snakes not one snake not one
snake
did you ever get the snake emoji
no because uh isn't that a thing if
you're like if people say like if you're
like two-faced it's like a snake emoji
oh did i ever get you your like
character on the show emoji yeah oh like
taylor that was like a top it was the
cringe of the snake
cringe in the sink oh then you gotta go
to um uh or cloud you go to night club
you got to go to ireland and do like a
no snake emoji because there's no snakes
in ireland oh i like that yeah lean into
it in your face but let me ask you
because you were doing like a shisty bee
thing what was that yeah the shyster
tell me about this well i've just
created my own llc actually i'm obsessed
i've got the business cards have all
shown up absolutely
llc so yeah i've got some things in the
works it's kind of like
for everyone that's been called a name
you know it's it's taking power in that
name in the in your shame and taking
power and just saying like
you know fuck off yeah and who i am like
at the haters
and owning it and owning it and knowing
that you're a good intention person
right and you're gonna
potentially be judged by others but it's
all it's about them it's not about you
the way that you perceive me is totally
about you so if you you know what you
see as shystee i see as brave and
vulnerable and risk-taking and you know
vigilant and
strident you know like that to you as
shystee or crazy totally fine like we
just have we speak different languages
you know um i recently
finally did this you know as my whole
career in life being called you know
crazy
um we were just doing this campaign with
the new june shine flavor and it's like
a picture of me and it says crazy
refreshing
and i was just like yeah i love that
it's so
like to me crazy bitch these to me are
all a compliment at this point so it's
like if someone's like um you're crazy i
now just go oh you mean i'm having more
fun than you and you don't like it yeah
i'm in my 30s you're uncomfortable yeah
i'm just having more fun than you right
a bitch
probably just means i stood up for
myself and you didn't like it right
totally you know what i mean yeah
scheissdb probably just means you didn't
take the time to get to know me
and we didn't get a chance to really
attune to each other if that's what you
see and if you still believe that you're
just not going out of your way to get to
know who i am so that's just more like
representative of your choices than me
you know so just being able to sort of
alchemize all of those things into into
something positive and it's not my
limitation it's yours absolutely yeah so
what are you are you gonna like
am i allowed to ask you about
um yeah so some things are kind of under
wraps but i would be so psyched to have
like a push-up sports bra that said
scheissdb
i'm so into it should i take one of
those
but also for like two you should have it
be a different color in the front and
the back so there's like two faces you
know what i'm saying it's different in
the front and the back i love that you
have to win right now you have to have
koozies you have to have wine coozies
you have to have like little wine things
you know how many people how many wine
companies have approached me obsessed
everyone wants a dog wine
everyone wants me to make a dog wine you
make a wine for the for their human and
then you make a dog or a wine for their
dog okay and it's like i don't know if i
can really lean in that that much you
guys yeah
um
how about a
oh uh how about this
because you do you already said i did i
was anxious i was nervous i don't feed
my dog wine
what if it's a
cannabis or like a hemp infused just
drink
that's no wine because we don't give our
dogs wine but it's w-h-i-n-e no whining
like when there's fireworks or
thunderstorms to calm your dog down
genius when it's whining genius which
was the first one last night in like the
history of l.a last night i was with my
dogs they were freaking out in the
thunderstorms and i was like i just had
a little cannabis treat or a hemp treat
something that would calm them i think i
gave one of my dogs i had to give them a
benadryl um because they were gonna yeah
she was like hurting herself so scared
and so the no wine so no wine for dogs
drives home that message and it's
w-h-i-n-e oh yes
i like this idea yeah i was so anxious
last night we had left for the doctor
canoodling event and peyton was home
alone and it started thunder and
lightning and i was dogs and
thunderstorms is really it can be they
can hurt themselves if they get really
really yeah fireworks yep it was just
like wild like crackling so you should
have something standing by to slightly
sedate them if they're a danger to
themselves when fireworks come
absolutely especially if you can't be
there or thunderstorms to comfort them
i'm just saying
but like are you online you need to cash
in on every single thing
like that is the move
okay right
i mean
it's so weird because
you know i haven't done anything
anything that i've done up to this point
i've given to charity because i hate
reality
television like
you know like i the optics and the way
that people behave
or sorry what we see all the kind
moments all the sweet moments no one
cares about those because they're
they're not producing adrenaline in our
brains so
you know it's like you know people
have a bias towards negative comments
people come on here like i just got all
these negative comments i'm like i'm
looking at your feed you have like
ten out of a thousand are negative but
those are the only the ones you see
because the other ones just aren't
giving you dopamine and adrenaline it's
true so the same thing with that is so
true all the moments in those whatever
40 days that were boring or banal or
kind or
they just didn't make the cut yeah no it
that's the truth you see a very small
snippet of what happened over you know
it's just all the most negative moments
it's true i think for me it's somewhat
you know i try to not
it's like i have a career and i love it
you know and then there's this stuff
over here and um i love it i love it i
love an entrepreneurial career but
you've been called for something bigger
yeah you've been called it's like not
it's not up to you yeah am i being a
bully no i love it it's not it's not
inspiring like something hap like like
the universe god whatever it like picked
you and was like nope we there's more
for you to do yeah like we want more
from you like you were put on this earth
like you have a bigger purpose whether
it's to like
you know
draw attention to like people's you know
um
essentially
you know
overcompensating because of their own
stuff pointing at someone else and going
oh that's my ego blaming someone else
and like trying to distract from my own
why am i focusing on this person's
behavior like instead of looking at mine
or whatever it was whether it's the
catharsis or holding a mirror up or um
some kind of like it almost to me felt
like
it broke reality tv in a way
yeah you know what i'm saying like i
think that
after that
less sane people will sign up to do
reality television you know what i'm
saying i think a lot of people saw that
and we're just like oh
like yeah you can't be a good person
with good intentions and do this you're
gonna get fucked yeah
does that make sense it's the same thing
happened in politics where now i'm at
the point and i never talk about
politics on the show if you're running
for office i already don't want to vote
for you because you want to run for
office right because you know what
you're getting into yeah like you're
already you're already like a narcissist
like
this being in politics is so brutal and
what you have to do in order to become a
politician is so gross at this point
that
i don't want to vote for you if you want
to run
it's a red flag you know what i'm saying
yeah same thing with reality tv it's or
what happened to you
and in the
ideas that you have about people who
sign up for reality television um and i
think i was maybe different than that
and i think that's
when you're like bringing this out of me
right now um maybe that's why i don't
want to go
here's my fab fit fun box i just got off
love is
i felt that i did this for the right
reasons
and that's why i've continued on the
same career path that i have but it's
it's um true that i do feel
i want to give back i want to
you know a little community that i've
formed um and that's formed around me to
get me through everything because that's
what happened essentially everyone that
got through to me and that told their
stories to me that's what got me through
that like people dming you and i wasn't
able to tell my story up until i was
able to tell my story
so i want to get back to those people
for sure but i think that but you but
you it's like
sorry to bully you out of kindness here
but it's like you know when you give
someone a gift and they send you a thank
you note
and then you're like oh i have to send a
thank you note for the thank you note
like you gave to them and they gave back
it's over the transaction's over okay
you don't need to give any more you gave
it all you know you were of service by
sort of
you know i think you went on the show
without to me i was like oh that's not
someone that's like super savvy that
knows exactly what to do on a reality
show to be cut assert like to me you
were just like this clearly this bright
light like sweetheart that was like oh
no she's gonna just be genuine and
sincere and not calculated and cunning
this is uh-oh you know yeah so it was
like you weren't going in with this like
business brain of how i'm going to be
perceived and how i'm going to play this
game and how to have a strategy
you were just like i'm just kind of
trying to fall in love and you know i
have all the other boxes in my life
checked like i'm full you know i'm not
here to make enemies whatever and then
so now why can't you have a strategy now
yeah why can't you capitalize on this
yeah you got a great point that's a
great point you got fucked it in my
opinion so why can't you alchemize that
into something positive yeah and go like
yeah i'm gonna go make a million bucks
off that show yeah why can't you do that
that's a good point because i don't like
the idea that you got it's like what i'm
talking about with when amanda knox was
on it was like after amanda knox was
wrongfully accused and she was again
that i couldn't like take money for
speaking appearance because i didn't
want to seem like i'm capitalizing on
someone else's you know
you know misfortune murder um it's like
but that's not you got screwed yeah you
know like i think of all the stuff you
lost during this time like if you
if you take any money for this you're
still not even gonna be
like close to where you
would have been had this never happened
to you like you're owed
i'm saying
you don't owe anyone anything that's
what's making me that's what's why do
you owe people that got you through it
i don't know they owe them or like right
but to continue that community yeah and
the lessons that we've all taken out of
this right with
some of the things that were spent that
were spinning towards the mail yes yes
yes stories yes yes bitches be crazy
much better than ours yeah um i would
like to continue those lessons and
somehow triangulate that
um
because now i see it i watch reality
television very differently now and i
see like exactly what's happening and um
you know to be able to make an impact i
should say i want to make an impact yeah
right because at the end of the day i
think that's why i went through
everything i went through um and i think
the best thing to show people is like
you can walk through hell
and like make it work for you yeah i
mean i'm making the sports bras i'm
making this like lean into your inner
chest db like what whatever your most
embarrassing mistake you've ever made
publicly like go with it like don't
allow that to be the end of the story
yeah that's only the end of act two
you know totally like the end of the
story is actually triumphant like that
wasn't the end yeah that was just the
midpoint like i think there's something
incredible about that you know and and
owning that and showing people that like
because most people are not famous but
you know i think there's something so
relatable about getting whatever kind of
modicum of fame you have whether it's in
your office building whether it's in
your gym whether it's whatever you fart
in your soul cycle class and then you're
you gotta go back the next day and it's
like all right let's all get fart out
like just figuring out a way to just get
through these embarrassing things and
and the muscle of resilience like i
think it seems like you've been called
on a very huge level to
illustrate that trajectory
yeah
jim saying there's no the the
universe gave you all this fame around
this thing obviously it wasn't just to
end here yeah it was like
netflix and whatever they're making a
bunch of money off you why can't you
make money off you
i've i've wondered that many times yeah
why can't you go make a bunch of money
off of your
stuff and yeah donate it great yeah but
why can't you
do that
because you feel like
you're gonna
they already used you why can't you use
you totally you know that's a good point
it's a good point there's some things
coming yeah good okay good there's
something in the door
there are things in the world good good
um so there's more to be seen um netflix
is releasing love is blind the second
season in february okay so there is
something that i'll be coming out with
that will parallel nice so um
more to come on that nice i want like a
journal line like my side of the story
oh i like that like a journal
like i want
i want like
um like i want like a wine glass that's
like you know has a
oh the gold
like a like it has like um what is it
like little markers of like
uh
oh yeah electronics
you're going to own apology tomorrow
l.i.b bachelorette party exactly
yeah totally like just just stuff to
like to me the only way to get out of
these sticky places is to have a sense
of humor about yourself totally and
that's when you're really healed when
you can laugh yeah absolutely you know
yeah absolutely and i think if there's
anything that can be taken from seeing
the entire experience soup to nuts it's
like i was in a place where i felt so
much pressure from everyone around me
you're 34 what's wrong with this guy
that you broke up with what's wrong with
this guy that you weren't interested in
and everyone around me is settling down
into what america or the world deems as
like traditional appropriate times and
age and all these things and i'm going
like i'm the odd man out i'm alone you
know i'm spending the weekends by myself
and my friends are multiplying yeah so
do something as crazy as sign up for the
show
in the first season
to try to make a connection
and just even that example seeing what
plays out and how difficult it was for
me because i chose to do that
i think should shine a light on a
serious problem that we have as as
in any relationship that we have
whatever gender we are when we feel so
pressured that something's wrong with us
that we haven't you know gotten to a
certain place in our lives
you know so much that our friends are
even pressuring and harassing us about
it you know um
it's gotta stop and even people reach
out to me do you still want kids do you
still this finally this fine it's very
it's that's
um
doesn't feel good you know and this is
happening to
everyone it happens to everyone yes you
get
thousands of people tired of this like
but everyone gets reality on some level
whether it's they go home for
thanksgiving and they get the questions
from their aunts like everyone has to
deal with this right but i agree but i
think i hope that tides can change on
that
second um i heard that you froze your
eggs after the show
yeah
what made you do that
i'd always been thinking about it and i
was like obviously i'm really far from
settling down
so um
i'm just gonna do this and the process
was horrific
to be honest i went to one of the best
in the biz i think all the bachelor
people go to him too um should they be
procreating
sorry can we can we shut that business
down
okay
wow grace emily
big night
uh i'm not trying to shame you guys at
all you just you look a little bit
your hair is tousled you look like
you've got that bed head going
let's just say i didn't get a ton of
sleep last night
tell me about it that gilmore girls
marathon on the cw was wild is that a
euphemism
whitney what was that thing that you
were telling me about um the pill club i
think i need to sign up for that oh
thank god you brought this up because i
want to talk about it too i think i need
the pill club oh pill club is the best
they're a birth control subscription
service and they carry over 120 fda
approved brands most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or with
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as seven dollars per month without
insurance and the pill club delivers
birth control to your door
for free indiscreet pr packaging what's
better than that okay so what brand you
want tylenol yasmine
what
wait what
tylenol that's the brand of pill i'm on
i got too excited during the gilmore
girls my iphone last night and when just
went in to kiss rory and i
fell out of bed and yeah you can say
that i needed tylenol delivered to my
door a stat
ah that's not
what we thought what's yeah what's a
yasmin who's yasmin
control phil
do you guys not use a sponge
a sponge emily please pay attention to
this focus hard focus up focus hard
right now when you go to
thepillclub.comwhitney the pill club is
offering 10
of a donation to bedsider.org for every
good for you with whitney cummings
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through
bedsider.org that's thepildclub.com
whitney to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember the pill club.com
whitney you must use the link to make a
donation and if any of you would like to
make a donation to emily please direct
message her
via whitney's accounts
if you would like to make a donation of
sperm to emily
through whitney's account
all right i just i've been having these
crazy headaches recently so i'm just
trying to go through these
old medical textbooks to see if there's
any information
it's probably the dust coming off the
textbooks that's giving you the
headaches okay
grace um
that
i see why you think that's
true it does smell a little musty but i
i
oh no this says i need a lobotomy
wait no i'm sorry that was just my
reminders list on my
phone okay a book that old is going to
tell you that you have polio um have you
ever heard of zok dock
okay i don't need your gen z witchcraft
grace i've
wanted to brush my teeth the charcoal
too is that it how about that look this
book actually said if i want to relax
more i should start to smoke like take
up smoking are we in an episode of mad
men okay whether you need a primary care
physician a dentist a dermatologist a
psychiatrist an eye doctor or any other
specialist zocdoc has you covered my god
wait a second this looks right it says
that i need leeches
leeches do you does whole foods sell
leeches maybe in the ceviche section
i really hope not um but also i know a
more modern way to go about this if
you're interested because every month
millions of people use zocdoc and i'm
one of them it's my go-to whenever i
need to see a doctor and i really think
you need to check it out
okay you're talking about calling a
doctor okay i know what this i know what
that is you call but then you gotta wait
three days right for them to send out
like a what a smoke signal out of their
office let us know when it's time to
make an appointment great can you get me
one of the phone books like a yellow
book so i don't even know what that is
with zocdoc you can search for local
doctors who take your insurance read
verified patient reviews and book an
appointment in person or video chat
never wait on hold with a receptionist
again so just download the free zoc doc
app which is the easiest way to find a
great doctor and instantly book an
appointment you'll get to search
specifically for the kind of doctor
you're looking for and even read reviews
but left by other patients what
this doctor lets you write reviews and
like give feedback and like
talk about their
their
medicine behavior the doctors i see
don't let me do that the doctors i see
always say shh
don't tell anyone about this now is the
time to prioritize your health and
zockdoc makes healthcare easy go to
zocdoc.com whitney and download the
doctoral app to sign up for free and
book a top rated doctor many are
available as soon as today that's
sockdoc.com
whitney yeah that's
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash whitney yeah i
was
in chicago shooting myself up with
hormones every night and your body just
takes a toll on your body so really
think about it you are it's examples you
are going to you're getting four months
pregnant you're pumping up
you're pumping up your body
and you're creating all these eggs more
eggs than you're supposed to create
naturally right and it takes a toll on
you yeah i was getting hot flashes
and um
you know my stomach was just bruised and
black and blue everywhere yes because
you're constantly just stabbing yourself
with needles twice a day
right and then you have to go in every
couple days to get the sonography
constantly being monitored and so that
that's what got me the most is i was
like okay i'm freezing my eggs i can
stick a needle in myself for a month
like no problem right and um
it was the oh no you have to drive in
every three days hour i mean let's be
honest going to any doctor's
appointments three hours door to door by
the time you get there and it was like
oh i didn't realize i was gonna be in
the car sitting in traffic already
hormonal and you know i didn't know how
much time it was going to take from me i
was like i might as well just have a kid
at this point that's right
absolutely three hours a day like this
is what like it was just so
frustrating and then ever in the amount
of money that it costs was even more
frustrating yeah
but after i did it i did have this
weight lifted off me that i didn't even
know it was there it was very much like
oh my god i didn't realize
how much stress i was carrying of
thinking i have to i'm i'm rotting from
the inside basically like i was so
going into every relationship with
are you a father are you a father are
you a father and that's not fair to the
other person you know to just
put all that pressure right away it took
a lot of pressure off that i didn't even
realize was suffocating me oh wow until
after i did that it might be delusional
it might be a magical thinking because
the technology is pretty good but if i
think i got 18 eggs when i was 33 so oh
that's great but like half of those get
freezer burn or there's problems or
whatever and let's say you have a i
think it's like a 35 or 40 chance if
you're gonna use those frozen eggs later
embryo freezing embryos actually has a
higher chance but like so yeah but still
there was something that was like okay
i'm not going to settle
absolutely it's nice
it makes you feel like you have like
five more years absolutely than you did
before that's how i feel yeah it's an
insurance policy for sure yeah that's
what it was and yeah i felt great after
i i have to say i did the trigger shot
you remember that bad boy it goes in the
booty oh my god
before trigger is your cycle
yes
and i actually almost died
because my throat started closing and i
it was a night my dad had been staying
with me but he wasn't there i had to
drive myself to northwestern memorial in
chicago
my throat was closing and it was all
kinds of whack jobs at the er and i was
like trying to get to anyone to help me
it was wild but yeah i did almost
and then mine was afterwards so i have a
whole chapter in my book about this so i
don't want to be um
redundant but i had um what is it called
when you uh hyper stimulation so
when they extract the eggs which i have
a video of me that emily took because
emily was with me when i had my eggs uh
extracted down in redondo beach i was
high off my mind i know who you went to
dedicate these eggs
to my homies
tell them how many
you haven't eaten i had 20 eggs
i was very very high but he basically
was like just
one day bed rest which for overachievers
like us it's like bed rest means like
just like don't ski
like that's what my my brain heard like
don't bungee jump right so i'm like up
i'm working i'm driving around and what
happens is because you have all these um
holes basically in your ovaries and if
they fill up with water it's really
really bad so i was in fetal position
for like four days the irony and uh i
got hyper stimulation my i guess ovaries
filled up with water or something i had
to call casey wilson i talked to her
about this on the show so i'm not
throwing the best i could not
take a poo poo for like five days i did
like
mucinex it was like this whole saga so i
just made it harder on myself because by
the time it was done i was so frustrated
that i was like i have to get back to my
life like i can't do this anymore
absolutely you know because you are four
months pregnant basically yeah like i
was i was huge i was
you know i was like constipated i was
annoyed i was just like oh i should have
just like done another four months and
had this freaking thing and put it on
ebay or whatever people did
and uh so yeah it was just it was
definitely very frustrating because
i think that our generation we come up
we came up kind of hearing like you
could have it all you can have it all
it's like oh i finally make my own money
i can freeze my eggs and it's like this
is
not what was promised to me
by all those girl boss ted talk pictures
you know what i mean yeah yeah this is
hard and it's frustrating and it's
painful and i feel like i'm at war with
my body and i feel like biology is
sexist like i'm not mad at hollywood i'm
not mad at social norms i'm mad at like
my body for like
petering out and rotting when i'm
getting
my brain is the best it's ever been like
when i'm finally qualified to be a
mother that's when my body
like gives up that's how i just now feel
ready you know yes yeah so it's like
what i'm do i had all these eggs when i
was 25 when i was a little moron
drinking mike's hard lemonade senior
frogs that's when i was the most fertile
like this makes no sense it's crazy and
then you're learning about it and you're
33 34 and you're like damn
um but you know i think it's a good age
33 i did mine at 34. awesome so awesome
awesome and the idea is
it's not necessarily for your first or
second kid this is this is what my
doctor really um hammering home for me
which is that this is an insurance
policy number one so that you're not so
stressed out about getting pregnant that
you shut your body down and can't
because a lot of people the harder
you're trying the harder you're trying
sometimes you're producing enough
cortisol to make your body go this is
not a safe environment to procreate so
you know so many of my friends they'll
stop trying after six months oh my god
we just got wasted one night and that's
when i got pregnant it's because your
body finally relaxed and became a
hospitable environment for
you know yeah so that's why so many
animals um don't procreate in captivity
because their body is so stressed out
that they can't you know conceive so our
body knows when we're stressed out it
doesn't know that you're stressed out
about conceiving you know yeah so it
just knows you're stressed and like this
is not a good time to procreate and um
so he was like this is for your third or
fourth kid when you're 41 and you're
like you know what i think we're gonna
do one more or
something went sideways you're like
maybe i'm gonna get a surrogate or maybe
i'm gonna put this with an embryo like
you just wanna have it so that you're
never going uh i wish i had interesting
my doctor said something different
interesting so my doctor said
you'll oh you'd always want to use the
eggs first
huh
maybe he's a better salesman
but because i was gonna ask for you try
naturally exactly because i was gonna
ask you because he said always use your
younger eggs then trying to get pregnant
at say 37 versus your 34 year old eggs
your 34 year old eggs um you know would
be the better candidates is what so i
was going to ask you the question would
you
prefer to get pregnant naturally or
would you prefer to
go the ivf route with the 33 year old
eggs oh my gosh well as a licensed
doctor um infertility specialist that
has been
taking the boards and everything
i don't know that's a tricky one my gut
instinct
which has served me horribly in
relationships but great in work so i'm
not sure where how it serves me
fertility wise and family planning wise
um
i would say i would want to try
naturally first i i feel the same way
because even though i got that advice i
still feel like i want to do it
naturally if possible if possible i mean
the whole point of freezing the eggs is
that i can do it naturally because i'm
not stressed out about the eggs it's a
stupid system expensive system
unfortunately but then i have a backup
plan
and can use those if i need to
in a jam or for my second or third later
i like that strategy you know because i
just think it'd be great to go the next
natural way it's possible like a hundred
grand cheaper i feel like oh yeah
no totally
i'm going to follow up on this like
actually i need you like i i feel like
he has a mortgage payment to make
exactly yeah
i'm going to follow that i feel like
your fertility doctor has a gambling
problem
it's like
you should pay for ivf in cash uh today
i don't know
i mean yeah i
i don't know i i do think though as as
shitty as it is i would like to
get pregnant naturally just to know that
i could and that all the horrible
decisions i made for the past 30 years
didn't like break my body
and then i'm not just like a programmed
robot like um you know putting out you
know like i would like to just have that
like experience i think also just as a
comedian i'm like i need some jokes and
i feel like i just
probably get some out of the pregnancy
will give me something which i'm but
pregnant
totally yeah so i feel like i just
should have that experience but i'm also
fine with
not i'm i also have no ego in it because
there's so many women that can't get
pregnant naturally there's so many times
you have miscarriage and
it's not your fault like i wouldn't
be mad at myself if i couldn't but it
would absolutely i think i'd get a lot
of jokes out of it hell yeah which is
totally which is totally worth it but i
also think if i got pregnant
via
like ivf or surrogate i'd hate my child
a little bit less
saying i know like people that have
surrogates
have their kid they love their kid
because they're not like you ruined my
body they're sort of i'm telling you you
get to employ a woman
uh to have your child for you
and
you know a lot of people in tricky
circumstances could really use that cash
and then you're not you know like you
ruined my vagina and you're going to cry
you know together yeah
it's like adopting your own kid
yeah
sort of so i i have no shame on any of
it i just feel like we're at a point
where we have to let go of how we think
marriage should be childbirth should be
timelines i just think it's with online
dating with the technology now it's like
you can get married at 22 and be with
them forever and have five kids godspeed
or you can get married at 45 have your
first kid at 46 and get a divorce at 50
if you like every like there's no
one way that fits everyone anymore
exactly that's the biggest thing i've
learned is like i never would have
thought i'd be in the position that i'm
in
um you know marrying someone with kids
like i never would have thought i would
do that and i'm like oh my gosh i have
this family that i've always wanted and
i love them you know i
never would have thunk it although i'm
adopted by my dad i didn't know that
yeah i'm adopted by my dad and do you
know your birth parents or no do you
want to nope
well my mom had me that's my real mom
but my dad um adopted me when i was like
two
i know nothing else and it's this crazy
nature versus nurture study and now i
feel like well if i'm not meant to have
kids right or um
kids of my own i love the adoption idea
because me and my dad are so close i
would never know you know we don't even
talk about it it's never brought up
because it's like i even look like the
guy it's it's so wild and he's like my
best bud um does so i'm totally ready to
pay it forward if none of the above
options work out and you know we go the
adoption route i love it and it's like
maybe that's meant to be my story have
you seen three identical strangers
no three identical strangers is this
documentary on amazon of these triplets
i don't want to ruin it and i'm such i i
throw spoilers out left and right if you
haven't seen it that's on you i'm not
walking on eggshells
spoilers are coming but i do not want to
spoil this for you
um which is three identical strangers
about triplets that were in an
experimental study they were separated
at birth
oh wow it's it's a very unethical thing
that they did this adoption agency and
how their lives took different paths and
it's it's worth seeing but
wildly fascinating nature versus nurture
in terms of that do you have any desire
to meet your quote-unquote real dad even
though this is your real dad none you're
good whatsoever i feel nothing
i don't know it you know it's like i
don't know that and i don't feel this
whole thing so because that that to me
sums up
no one has any questions about how like
down to earth and chill and grounded you
are but that sums up your lack of a need
for drama so it's like
like
the
that's just fascinating to me because
i'd be so curious i'm like i gotta know
i gotta
you do not have the need to stir up shit
which is
the opposite of how you were portrayed
on the show
jeremy i'm saying yeah somebody's like i
don't need to be my biological dad like
i'm good like i don't need that drama
like like i'm good
you're like kind of an i'm good person
and it is like antithetical to the way
you were conveyed or
on that show yeah well it's interesting
because i feel like that would have been
a bad hand right and what i was blessed
with was so much better than that so why
would i look back yeah yeah yeah and uh
it's that just reminded me i um was in
portland this is the most portland thing
that's ever happened
i in my new hour i'm talking a lot about
23andme test and ancestry test and
whether i should do it with the guy that
i'm with before we have kids like should
we know it okay and um and i ask people
if they've done it and it's so it's a
very intense moment because
i i would say half the people have done
23 and me
find out they have another sister or
that their dad it's not their dad i mean
it's wild what's going on there was
someone
a guy approached me about writing the um
uh movie version of this there's a guy
in florida i think he's like a tennis
instructor now or something
in the
60s 70s if your man was shooting blanks
they the hospital wouldn't tell him that
because you can't tell a man like you're
shooting blanks it has to be the woman's
fault always
so like a
nurse tech or like an intern or just
some guy that works in the medical
office would jerk off yes and they would
inseminate
women disgusting
so a lot of women were getting pregnant
by just random guys at hospitals and we
all just pretended this was the father
because he was shooting blanks there's a
guy in florida who has had like 90
something people contact him he has a
greeting that's like hi yes my name is
so-and-so i know you probably found me
on 23andme this is the situation give me
your number and i'll call you back when
i can
and i can talk to you for 10 minutes
like he's got all these boundaries he's
got like a whole system set up because
he has so many
children that he sired because he was
like they told me to jerk off a new cup
what else he's like anticipated in that
you can't believe he i mean what choice
did he have he's not he has a voice
greeting that's like an auto greeting
and they asked me to write the movie
version of all of them meeting um
he was entertaining the idea of going
should we have one party where i just
meet everyone once and like we sign a
thing that says like we never meet again
let's just meet for one night say hi and
we never have to meet again
that's an uncomfortable party to attend
very if you've been to some
uncomfortable party
i wouldn't sign up to go to that
and so i was talking to uh i was talking
about on stage and this girl goes you
know i finally tracked my dad down i've
been looking for him for 30 years and
i'm like oh my god
that's crazy what happened she goes it
was a nightmare and i was like why she
went
he's a scorpio
adoption i would totally do that too
would you yes i have a friend who's just
done it and she's about to do it again
and it's beautiful well also i like
i rescue dogs like you know that's my
whole thing i kind of feel like having
my own kid is like buying a dog from a
breeder
i mean there's so many kids that need
homes you know
exactly and my dad's side family is from
west virginia and there's like this
nightmare foster care situation there
where kids are being born addicted to
opioids like so that's
they sound chill
you know
right
i'm like i'm in so
so they don't cry a lot they're just
they seem like they probably sleep a lot
but no i can i can totally see myself
doing that because it's like i know what
i come from i know my genetics i don't
want to load up some kid with what i i
would love the idea of being like yeah
let's
let me have someone else's ancestral
nightmare in my house because i know
what mine is and i don't need it
reflected back to me you know at least
like if i adopt every time the kid's not
i'm like that's not my thing right
not my fault
that's nature not nurture that's a
nature thing that's on you your parents
probably smoked
i rescued you
i feel like you'd have a lot of leverage
yeah i feel like parenting an adopted
kid i'd be like i'm going to take you
back to the shelter
[Laughter]
sounds very this is us yeah yeah yeah i
just would like to yeah i would like to
have as much leverage as possible over
my kid i like that idea and you do i
know people that have both biological
children and adopted children
and they do say that they have weirdly a
tighter bond with their adopted children
that's how it is on this is us what is
that mandy moore is
is more
uh attached to sterling brown
yes
what is that i
i don't know and i wonder if
um just thinking about my relationship
with my dad
the the kid was laughed you know that
the person that created they like you
more because they didn't have to see any
of your shit or change your diapers you
didn't have to watch my show yeah
you probably watched my show and goes
okay that was a good decision on my part
no way my my dad maybe you know because
i look back now and i'm taking care of
two kids and i love them dearly um and
my my dad you know i just look back and
i'm like
how did he feel so tightly connected to
me that he wanted to adopt me and take
me as his own you know and it's it's
such a cool thing but i feel like
because it's a choice it's a choice and
i didn't have a dad you know i was like
this
um
you know when you are born and someone
signs off their rights from you
so the dad in that case goes nope i
don't want anything to do with this
person and i will never want anything to
do with this person for the next 18
years they have to sign that document
you become a word of the state
so i had like two different last names
uh and then you know my dad starts
dating my mom and he's probably just
going this kid is so lost you know like
this person didn't want her and you
probably feel just a tight connection
because you didn't want you like he's
like he didn't want anything like i tell
i say he's my hero because he swooped in
he saved me and you know there's there's
a connection in that for sure
that's amazing and then hey i got
hammered and slept with someone yeah
like my choice
i'm not taking care of you because i
have to i'm doing because i want to
totally you know what i'm saying yeah i
never actually thought about that until
now because i don't think about it i
don't think about the fact that i'm
adopted but because if you sire a child
it's your obligation it's like what we
talked about before the quote about it
this is not his obligation he's choosing
to do it yeah so that is such an amazing
place to be for a child like actually
adopted children going like okay yeah
this person that rejected me didn't know
me so he didn't reject me he didn't give
you up he didn't know you yes you were a
blob right right and so um there's
something kind of amazing about being
like but this person has chosen me every
single day yeah
you know it's cool that's pretty awesome
yeah it really is it's like our
relationship is is awesome yeah it's so
great i would adopt
yeah that's sick yeah and it's it's it's
awesome because there's also like a you
don't take that for granted either
because it's like i don't i think if you
have your own kid you're like i know you
you're one of me but it's like who are
you like i don't really know you and i
have to kind of honor
all this other nature that i don't know
so i have to like get to know you as a
person instead of just assume you're
exactly like me yeah that's true and
also but be impactful and introduce you
to things in my life and it's which is
what something i'm experiencing is being
like a
soon-to-be step parent yeah it's the
coolest thing
and i also love what you said about like
i never thought i'd be with some of the
kids we we make all these like hard and
fast rules to make ourselves feel safe
or making our you know really our lives
feel like they have some kind of order
or whatever
we need our lists but i find the more
things i had on my list
that were hard and fast rules or bottom
lines
actually the opposite the contrary
action was the healthiest for me i was
like i'll never date a guy that has kids
i said that because i was like i don't
want him to have this intimate
connection with someone else or i don't
want because secretly in my brain i go
like well the mom is going to be the
number one and i'll always be coming
second like it was my ego and my
insecurity right it's great to come and
second after someone's kids that's
awesome that's like that's a guy's
priorities in the right place he's not
running around like you're not coming in
second like hookers and drugs and like
you know wings and the patriots you know
what i'm saying what a great thing to
come in second to
in a way and then you're not second
because then you become a family with
them exactly and he's responsible like a
guy that's already a father is like oh
he already has kids yeah he's has less
testosterone their testosterone goes
down and he has a schedule he has to be
on time he knows the like how to attune
to children like it's the i used to
think it was a red flag now it's i
almost
think it's weird if a guy doesn't have
kids or hasn't been married before right
yeah it's that's a good point and it's
too like he shows up when he's supposed
to and to propose after like i know
marriage is hard i know it takes
compromise and i know sometimes it
doesn't work and i'm going to do it
again with you
that is so hot yeah i agree and um
that's been a lot of uncomfortable
conversations to get to a place where
you know like you said it is hard like
i never imagined i'd be you know
marrying someone you know it's his
second time um but it's your second time
ish
child
that didn't count a child
that's 47 days of my life
point taken point taken
um
but
yeah it's it's interesting because i
don't have to wait to see what kind of
daddy's gonna be i already see that i
love it and um you know it's a much more
kind of intimate connection because i
get to see him in that and he's
introduced me into it which is like the
ultimate
uh gesture
um
so it's it's really cool but yeah it's
crazy how life can take you by surprise
the biggest thing i learned from love is
blind was i had all these checklists
the checklist embarrassing i can't look
back on that's the kind of thing that
annoys me when i look back but i feel
like i've grown so much from that
checklist of things that you wanted or
yeah thought yeah i would have not dated
a guy with kids but but i also think
it's important to have when we talk
about the show a lot red flags like you
have to know like this is not good this
is not good i'm looking for this like
you have to know what you want but not
be rigid about it it's a tough balance
you do have to have you have to know
where to give
and i think the biggest thing for me and
realizing ben was the one and never
having been able to do that before is
because i've been so blindsided in the
past and that screws you over when you
get blindsided and someone doesn't have
a conscience i've been in that situation
before with ben
the thing that um
made me totally fall in love with him
is
he
if he recognizes that something isn't
working he tries to do things
differently
and instead of
instead of blame or blaming the
situation and doing the same thing over
and over again expecting a different
result he's like you know what let me
pivot let me course let me try something
else exactly and i've never seen that
that's egoless that's someone that has
is without ego yeah and that is also
i mean
i love that means he's also an amazing
doctor because he's like i'm not going
to just try to make the thing work that
i've always done i'm just going to
adapt right he's adaptive he's adaptable
he's willing to compromise he's been
through a lot i've been through a lot so
i feel like we're able to meet each
other where we're at and it's
that's awesome something i haven't
experienced and then in uh is there
because i have this theory i know i'm
gonna let you go um eventually um you're
now being held captive again 47 days i'm
willing
to be honest um and uh
is that what was i going to say oh um
oh i have this theory that the things
you know you're in love that the things
that bother you with other people is
kind of charming with the person so bad
example
leave the top of uh leave the cap off
the toothpaste leave the cap off the
toothpaste that's annoying and then with
ben it's like babe what is it with the
cap of the toothpaste thing you crazy
totally is there and is that at all true
oh it's so that is true
that is true all of a sudden the thing
that used to nettle you is now kind of
endearing yeah everything he does i find
endearing um
and i mean
you know we're not perfect i get annoyed
sometimes um
like the that's in the sink like that's
normal i'm like babe
the dishwasher is not clean dishes i'm a
surgeon
i'm a surgeon right exactly
like let me you're saving people's lives
let me load this dishwasher
that like you can like cut up people's
feet but you can't put a plate
i could never date a foot surgeon
because that everything i'm like oh so
uh your foot surgeon yet you can't walk
four feet are your feet broken maybe you
should fix your own feet maybe you
should go do surgery on your feet so you
can walk over here and clean this up i
would be such a dickhead
i mean i give him grace
i work from home so i'm like all right i
can do some of these things but um yeah
it's interesting it is that's such a
good call out i hadn't thought about
that it's like the things that used to
annoy me like i find pretty much
everything he does endearing yes because
i think that a lot of times we go like
this is what i don't want this last
relationship i hate it when you did this
i hate it when you do this i'm going to
try to stay away from that
no it's probably going to happen again
in the next relationship you're just
going to weather the storm better or
it's going to be worth it or it's just
not going to be as annoying because it's
someone that you've decided like i'm in
totally and i think that's been the
biggest shift for me and something i've
never experienced is i always felt like
i was on my own team like i'm pretty
competitive person i've played sports
like i played college softball i love it
um like i've always been on a different
team than the person i was dating which
is so strange which is i
i have i'm like always like what are you
thinking what are you going to do to
like sabotage this because i've been in
bad relationships okay um you're the one
i mean it's you horrible like
when you're on a different team it's
horrible with ben and i don't know if it
was it probably was when he proposed um
i never felt like i was on a different
team with him but i finally feel like
i'm on the same team with someone huge
and i've never felt so like i've never
felt
less alone that is more alone what am i
trying left alone
you've never felt more alone hanging out
with me but you've never felt less alone
being with ben um this is a common
experience for people that come on this
podcast they start to feel very alone um
as soon as i start talking about
ancestral trauma two and a half hours in
um but that is fascinating to me because
i think
i it took me a long time to understand
that oh we're on separate teams it's not
about me winning or you i was like i
gotta win this fight i gotta win this
fight that implication is that we're on
different teams so if i win we both lose
right if anyone wins we've both lost and
there's this great book i think it was
um stan tatkin t-a-t-k-i-n
a friend of mine went to see him um
actually elena's more set when elena's
more said coming on the podcast
i know
we i
was having a nervous breakdown about it
and thank god we had to push it because
she's at the hollywood bowl tonight and
tomorrow okay and it was going to be
right before the show or whatever so
we're gonna do it in the future because
she's
literally there
there are very few people that i feel
like i'm not gonna be able to like
pull it together around like she's the
one
like she i will be sobbing
total fangirl moment and so i was uh she
actually did a bunch of episodes they're
really worth listening to she did a
podcast like
five or six years ago and it's just on
youtube and she talks to all these
relationship experts the woman that did
conscious uncoupling harville hendricks
who did getting love you want which is
all about how we're um attracted to
people with the negative qualities of
our primary caretakers changed my life
and then stan tatkin who's all about
attachment styles and figuring out what
your attachment strategy is right when
someone's fearful avoidant if you're
preoccupied you then become avoidant
like all that stuff that
even if you have just a cursory
understanding of it it helps you have a
little bit of awareness of going oh this
person is not an asshole they might just
be avoided oh this person's an asshole
they might just be have preoccupied
attachment strategy right because
basically the way that we attach to
people it was all decided by the time we
were three right uh based on how much we
could explore away from the parent and
then look back and see that we still had
their safety right and so um
he talks about something called the
couple bubble which i love and it's
about like before you go to a party
before you go into the the surgeon event
you you share your goals like you're
like um a football team in a huddle like
about to go in you're like okay
i don't want to talk to linda you know
that never ends well so if you see linda
talk to me i need you to come up and
help me got it because you know
otherwise you leave the party look i was
talking to linda for two hours why
didn't you help me right how would i
have known you looked like you're having
fun i watched it it's linda you know
what i'm saying like just stay i don't
want to talk to linda for more than 20
minutes i'm i don't want to eat here i
want to eat it in and out afterwards so
let's agree to not eat got it fist bump
um
are you drinking am i driving okay i'll
have two drinks you know what let's both
let's both have two drinks okay we'll
leave the car in the uber like you have
a plan and we'll leave by 11 15. got it
ready go so there's no like
dissonance in your goals in the party
okay and so there's no like when you
leave you're like bye everyone
right
like what i've been want to leave for
the past hour how would i have known
that yeah you know so you go in like
with a game plan and it was like news to
me
and it has really helped my
relationships oh interesting in the past
it didn't work out for other reasons
because there's a lot of like
oh parties socializing doesn't go well
because the person can't read my mind
you know because i i we all get socially
anxious right socializing can be a
nightmare yeah i get really embarrassed
there's certain things that i don't want
people to sometimes know like oh can we
not bring up the fact that i'm freezing
my eggs i just don't want to have to
talk about it the whole night you know
what i mean stuff like that why'd you
bring that up like i didn't know i
couldn't you know yeah so it's really
just getting a game plan together so
that you're set up to win
when circumstances start to shit it
starts to hit the fan and there's
elements that aren't in your control
like other people and whatever i like
that it's
a game changer
it's helped my friendships too
okay you're just walking to a party
willy-nilly with no plan it's insane
what has especially post coven what has
screwed up more relationships than going
into a party and leaving me like what
the fuck was that what do you mean what
the fuck was that what you were just you
just sat on the couch and watched the
game
we were supposed to leave it we were
supposed to be in and out we were like
it's your friend i don't like her well i
didn't know you didn't like her just
your friends like what the fuck are we
doing you know what i'm saying just like
getting on the same page no matter how
embarrassing it is
you know absolutely i want to read that
book because yeah it's like turning the
eye into a wii it's like it's it's a
cool empowering
we just did this thing together it's
like us versus this party
you know yeah like us versus the world
absolutely this feels toxic
this is literally like what sid the
speech sid gave nancy before they
overdosed and killed each other in the
bed
where's the june shine
i'm obsessed with you i i am i am mrs
i am so um
i was dreading this on some level you
were well i'm obsessed with you i'm
obsessed with you and i think it's more
just
you know
to to
i don't know i just when i watched that
i just i felt like
a human being was being traumatized yeah
you know what i'm saying
so
i think a lot of people watch reality tv
and they love that roman coliseum
element of it and tearing people apart
and i know that it's really just us kind
of
you know anesthetizing ourselves the
gross part of human nature yeah the sean
freuda of it all it's a real thing it's
someone that for a living embarrasses
myself so other people can laugh it says
my grossest things like i love that and
i love and i know how good it makes
people feel but i think watching it
happen to someone that
where it didn't totally feel consensual
was um
that was like heart rough you know it
was like rough but like to see
how this 180 of resilience and you just
like rise out of the phoenix and like a
phoenix out of the ashes like is like
the coolest thing
to see yeah it's really amazing because
i think we're we're all
we're all
in line for this
public embarrassment thing
all of us even if you're not didn't sign
up to be on tv the editor of vogue they
pulled up some tweets from 15 years ago
fi like everyone
on some level is like has the damocles
sword hanging of like what's you know
whether you're
you know have 30 followers on facebook
or the biggest show on netflix like
everyone's
done something
on camera that
could
embarrass them at any moment sure you
know so i think that you have shown
there is a way to you know a graceful
way to bounce back and this is just
gonna be part of our lives now this is
gonna be moving forward everything you
have ever said and done or posted will
follow you for the rest of your life
and
the only way to move forward is to have
a plan for how to be resilient and get
through it and know you're going to get
out the other side and your life's not
over absolutely because everyone is
everyone is going to go through this
every one of grace's generation ever
like this is the new normal
that something is on camera that's going
to haunt you for the rest of your life
but you're showing that it doesn't need
to be the end of your life it could be
the beginning of something even more
awesome absolutely and i i totally
appreciate that and i appreciate that
you were there in the beginning
challenging what you were seeing from a
news or entertainment
source coming into your brain right i
really appreciate that because when that
show came out did i think there was a
tomorrow did i could i see tomorrow no
you know as eloquent as i can be and
stand up and say
you know hey i'm the one chosen one and
i'm the strong one like it was brutal
and i didn't think there was a tomorrow
but i totally appreciate
people that were willing to challenge
the ideas that were being
tunneled into their brains
you know people now will reach out i'm
so sorry i had that opinion of you now i
can see a different side of you or
you've grown so much you know and
it's great to get those um but the
people that have grown so much since the
wine wore off you mean i just got
sobered up the next day i've always been
growing
like what are we doing because this is
what drives me nuts is like you know
everyone in college was binge drinking
and did some dumb stuff and in 20 years
is that video where you were drinking in
college gonna make you lose your job or
your kids in a custody battle moving
forward like you know in this in this
moment where we're all filming ourselves
at the dumbest moments and most
embarrassing moments of our lives
you know it doesn't have to haunt you
forever and we have to start going like
you know what
that person didn't mean harm by that
like we don't need to take the bait with
our human nature to get some kind of uh
fake victory out of someone else's
um
vulnerable weak moment right and i hope
that's been a lesson that's learned from
the second release of love is blind
seeing there was a whole different side
of the story and i hope now that when
people are watching these characters
that so
truthfully and bravely show up to do
these shows and put their hearts out
there on the line that as a viewer
you're experiencing it and seeing
there might be another side of the story
and that this is an entertainment yeah
venue yes and also for everyone that has
gone through anything like
when something happens and someone
gossips about you what do you want the
most someone just to hear your side
absolutely let me just tell you my side
of what happened like i totally see why
that's what he or she took away from it
but like let me just hear my side you
know right and uh yeah and i think
having some kind of post
partum plan after a reality show going
okay that happened now let's like paint
the full picture like that everyone got
to like laugh at that that was fun you
know the same way after actors do a
movie
they get to sit down and press jenkins
and go okay that sex scene was a
nightmare i we were freezing his wife
was there i was pregnant it was so
awkward like you know what i'm saying
everybody gets the opportunity to say
their side of the story but not often
not in reality television because you're
under contract you're under ndi
so always remember that right people
can't just come out after they go on the
bachelor and say oh here's what actually
happened you have to live with what they
show i guess signing that contract
prepares you for a marriage contract not
no contract is scary
well i couldn't imagine the couples that
got married you're in you're
tied to a contract with the production
company too so that was the thing that i
was like nope can't do
that like to have i'm sure your life
documented like yeah you're tethered to
it kind of forever so thank god
the marriage certificate we had to get a
marriage certificate went to the
courthouse and got it drawn up and that
was a bit traumatizing
um you didn't have time to do a prenup
there's no time
they wouldn't allow one even if you
wanted one well i guess i never asked
because i never knew i was going through
with it but
would take longer than like 11 days
i would want it to take longer than 11
days you want those things to be vetted
fully you know
um
he he might want a prenup he doesn't
want you to take all his protein powder
god forbid
um you're just a
wild brush breath of fresh air and i am
just i'm fascinated by you i'm enamored
with you and um i'm inspired by you
because i
have a lot of apologies to make after i
got uh drunk a couple weeks ago on this
program
all right can you just send me yours
i'll just copy and paste
yeah i do have that written out actually
so
and also the graciousness of may i say
apologizing more than you needed to just
because you knew it was
gonna make the situation dissipate it
was like you know what you're right i'm
just gonna take a
sorry i know you're christian so i'm
trying to not say take a dick in the
mouth um i'm you know what i mean it's
okay
just idea of like yeah i'll just be the
punching bag you know what sure that
apologizing for an edit
that was not you you know what i mean
apologizing like for like yeah i see
that that's how it came off
yeah and sincerely not going fine sorry
you were like sincerely let me just
enter into this reality that i was wrong
and apologize
right i i i would not be that big of a
person i wouldn't i wouldn't be able to
do it i'd be like are we am i really
apologizing for a crazy edit where i was
obviously drunk and obviously did not
want to date this guy with no top lip
and i'm apologizing
are you sure
wait now i need to see a
photo oh yeah
yeah that he has no top flip oh okay
yeah shows me nuts okay um but like i'm
just saying i would be the one that's
like
we're sure that i have to be sorry
for doing what everybody else did i just
managed to get shouldn't you guys all be
apologizing for me to me is that kind of
what should be happening there's a lot
of trade-offs you make sorry i'm getting
so angry that i'm when i showed up at
that reunion show nick lachey said thank
you for even coming here
i thought it was i thought it was i was
like that is the bravest bit that is a
level of brave bitch that
i can't even comprehend my girlfriends
stayed with me well my best girlfriend
stayed with me that night and i learned
what alka-seltzer was the next morning
yes put it in my mouth and shoved a
bagel in my mouth
and my friends they all intercepted me
from the airport the night before they
had a whole
strategy that was called love is blind
sucks and it was like this is what you
need to do these are this is your
contingency plan you get off instagram
you go fly to europe
and you live your best life are these
same friends that got you on the show
that sent you the email to get on it
one of them
look i feel like this is my problem to
solve right my other friend was an
attorney that was
mortified that i signed that on track
but
yeah so she swooped in and helped and
they were amazing but
they were the reason i got through that
day but um
yeah that was that was quite intense but
thank you for your kind words and thank
you for giving me this platform to come
in and speak about these things because
um
you know i've learned so much today and
i feel like if i can empower other
people um then i want to do that and now
i feel like i'm going to have some dog
wine yes no wine no whining no wine
with no wine but it's not wine it's no
it's no wine so no wine you don't give
wine to your dogs is it cbd but also no
whining like the dog's not gonna whine
when they drink that we do not condone
wine for dogs but
no we don't like whining for earthquakes
and stress so this is the no
w-i-n-e no wine
and no wine i'm gonna go trademark that
before like podcast comes out yeah dude
please it's like a hemp or something
it's like a hemp thing it landed yeah
it's a great idea and then also you
didn't whine you weren't like i mean and
things are hard you were just like yeah
that happened i got this cut this is
what i'm dealt with now i have to go
back to work while you guys go
bounce on yoga balls or whatever you do
for a living and uh i'm going to go be
an adult and sell software in silicon
valley
you know what i'm saying
right
like my foot surge with dexter my
husband dexter oh gosh
i think everyone's gonna listen to
listen to this day and go okay i thought
she was one thing and now i see that
there was so much else going on and it
was i saw such a tiny sliver of who she
was and her dog was sick and you know
she got lied to and she got you know um
uh the rug pulled out from under
everyone that
you run into in the world that cuts you
off in traffic that hits your grocery
card that's a that's a dick to you like
everyone
can be that everyone has is fighting
battles you don't know about everyone
has stuff going on that you don't know
about it's a way to just go like i can
radically forgive everyone because
everyone if i just heard them for three
hours on a podcast i'd fall in love with
them and be like oh i was wrong about
them yeah i just saw such a tiny sliver
of them yeah you know and
i don't need to use this one little
minute of their bad behavior or like
what i perceive to be bad
as a way to judge totally like i don't
have to take that ba i can just go oh
there's a lot i don't know and you my
therapist says this and it really helps
me when you know
i'll set her up like this guy yelled at
me and then he was like you know
screaming at me and then he was
screaming at the crew and she'll just go
sounds like he's in a lot of pain
i love that you know yeah and i would be
remiss if i didn't say
i told you i have no emotional
attachment towards the love triangle
situation in love is blind with amber
and barnett
but i honestly have so much respect for
her even though
she won't forgive me and she said
the worst things that have ever been
said to my face to me um
i know about her past i know things
she's been through that are horrifying
and i know personal stories about her
that i wouldn't share obviously but like
it helps me form
a belief about her and i know that she's
a well-intentioned person and that this
is all something else it probably has
nothing to do with me yeah and that's
what i think it's a lens that um you
know i'm trying to be better i'm
learning too and i think we all are
right because we perceive people's
behaviors coming at us but if we can
really look at it as
okay this person's been through all
these things this isn't about me anymore
they're just scared right and it's also
it's like when uh you know for me so i
spent so much time with animals
especially you know animals that have
been abused because you know when uh
when a you know a dog you get out of the
you know shelter out of abusive
situation growls you're just like oh
honey you're just scared right you know
like animals we forgive because they
don't have the words that confuse us
into thinking that they're more mature
than they are whereas like adults we're
kind of these five-year-olds dressed up
in you know tall five-year-olds in adult
clothes right pretending you know to be
adulting and
you know when
someone's angry with us or you know
nasty with us it's just like if an
animal did it would be like oh you've
been hurt but if a human does it we're
like oh you're mean it's like oh no this
is an involuntary reaction and we're all
just in fight or flight mode just in our
trauma responses you know it's amazing
that's just i think that's such a good
comparison because the way that we
relate to animals it's so much more
forgiving than the way we relate to
humans
and it's that's what i mean i have to do
this um i have this white tattoo um uh
white just kind of means it's like
you know it's scarification basically
but it's white ink and i just have to
because i would find myself
when i moved through the world to meet
someone my default would be like what do
you want from me
you're going to try to hurt me distrust
or i would take their behavior
personally and now i can just go like if
i spent three hours if you spend three
hours with anyone you'll fall in love
with them i don't mean like sexually or
like want to marry them i just mean
you'll like have compassion for them so
i try to just go how can i have
hindsight right now right okay like if i
spent three hours with you i would
forgive you i'd root for you i would be
able to have context for your behavior i
would have sympathy for you i'd relate
to you so let's just pretend we've
already spent three hours together i
already love you let's go i love you
are you doing the thing again where you
yell at me oh i know what that is that's
a great person you're just scared like
something bad has happened to everyone
we move through the world as if
everybody is in therapy five days a week
and had a perfect childhood right you
know i think most people are
well-intentioned people
and i think even narcissists it comes
from somewhere right because narcissists
are
uh really injured uh narcissists
especially
they project the image that their
primary caretaker would have approved of
exactly so it's it's someone that was
like deeply injured going well i'm the
best because that's what their uh
primary caretaker would have accepted
them in exactly it's a projection of a
false self right and and so i even you
know when people want to write off
narcissists it's even like you have to
give them grace
right we can give them grace but we
don't have to date them or marry them
yes
we also can block those motherfuckers
and delete the numbers with grace
um
i hope i get see i'm this is going on
too long we'll just have to talk more
and um i hope you'll be my friend i'm
already getting tickets to your san
diego no we'll get you tickets don't be
crazy okay i have i am literally i have
so many questions about my feet for your
fiance oh my gosh what a nightmare can
you get in line can you think of a
bigger nightmare than meeting everyone
you meet just she shows you their feet
he loves it
oh my god
okay
i have a lot of questions when i get
home
i love you guys don't write elephants
thank you jessica batten there's a
million underscores in her instagram i'm
not sure if they're the beginning and
the middle we don't know we don't know
we don't know this is we need to work
we're gonna we're gonna build this this
business up we're gonna get rid of that
underscore give me some ideas we're
gonna get the no wine dog business it's
happening love you guys don't write
elephants i have to let her pee
[Music]
[Applause]